what's up code squad my name is kylie
ying and today in this video i've
prepared 12
beginner python projects and i'm going
to walk you guys through the
implementations
for all of them now a couple of notes
before we begin
here's a list of all the projects these
projects are in order from
what i consider to be the easiest most
beginner friendly
to the most complex they'll range from
mad libs which is a string concatenation
to an unbeatable tic-tac-toe ai
to photo editing in python in addition
you might see me make a few mistakes run
into a few bugs
during these tutorials the reason why i
decided to leave these in there is
because i think
it's a very important skill to know how
to go back and fix your mistakes
because everybody inevitably makes
mistakes
and i thought it would be really good
for you guys to see some of my logic
when i go back and i fix them and of
course if you guys are interested
in more be sure to subscribe to my
youtube channel
kyla ying for coding projects and just
fun
computer science related topics follow
me on twitch kylie ying for
live streams of unedited coding sessions
and follow me on instagram and twitter
at kylie wying okay so let's get started
in a traditional mad lib you would have
a bunch of blanks in a paragraph
and you would have somebody fill out
those links and then read the paragraph
out loud
with the words that they chose in those
blanks
so we're going to recreate this project
in python
using string concatenation so let's talk
a little bit about string concatenation
in other words how do you put strings
together
so suppose we want to create a string
that says subscribe to
blank and this blank is going to be a
youtuber
so we can create a variable youtuber and
this is going to be some string
so there are a few ways to create the
string that says subscribe
to the youtuber
one way to do it is we can have the
string subscribe to
and then we can concatenate it with
youtuber by just adding a plus sign
the second way is to have a string
subscribe to
and then have these curly braces and
what we can do is we can call
string.format
youtuber and what this is going to do
it's going to put the youtuber
whatever the value of youtuber is into
where the curly braces are
in that string and now the third method
and what i think is the most
straightforward
is called an f string and
in an f string we can define this f
string by just
prepending an f in front of the string
and then we can say subscribe to
and then the curly braces and then
directly in the curly braces
we can add the variable name youtuber so
with an empty string let's try running
this real fast just to check that there
are like no errors and they all turn out
to be the same thing
so let's open terminal and run the
script
so here we see subscribe to blank
three times no errors okay everything
looks good so now let's try what the
youtuber actually filled out
to some string let's just try kylie ying
so let's run this again and you'll see
that now
all three of these print statements say
subscribe
to kylie ying and so for the sake of
this mad lib
we're gonna use the last one the f
string just because i think that's the
cleanest way
to express string concatenation
okay so starting this mad lib so first
we're just gonna assign
mad lib variable equals and then an f
string
so let's say computer programming is so
blank where blank is some adjective and
now we have to define this
variable adjective so we can say
adjective equals input
so here we're going to get a user input
and let's do adjective as a prompt
it makes me so excited all the time
because i love
to blank let's make that a verb
and this break right here this is just
saying
this is telling python hey this string
has gone on to the next line
that's all that little slash there is
stay hydrated
and verb two
like you are and let's make this a
famous person
exclamation mark okay so let's just use
that example right there
and now don't forget to define these
variables verb 1 verb 2 and famous
person
so up here we're going to say verb 1
equals input
and the prompt is just going to be verb
because all we want is a user to input
some verb
and now verb 2 is going to be the same
thing but instead verb 2 will be the
name of the variable
and then famous person again equals
input
so we're getting user input and we're
gonna say famous person
as a prompt okay so i actually have to
remove
this space and then
at the end we have to print the mad lib
to show the user
so that's it though now we can run this
code
alright so adjective let's do amazing
verb how about skydive
and then another verb jump and a famous
person
captain america
okay so our math lib is computer
programming is so
amazing it makes me so excited all the
time because i love to skydive
stay hydrated and jump like you are
captain america
and so yeah there you have it that's mad
lib in python
alright so if you guys actually download
my code which is linked somewhere below
you'll notice that there's a file called
randommadlibs.pi
what this is going to do is it'll choose
one of these four madlibs that i've
prepared
and it'll let you play that game all
right adjective
pretty another adjective soft
another adjective
a pretty glow burst suddenly across the
enchanted sky above them
as an edge of dazzling sun appeared over
the sill
of the nearest mask the light hit both
of their hand
at the same time so that voldemort's was
suddenly
a flaming water bottle what did i just
read
anyways there's a mad lib for you
first i'm going to teach you guys how to
implement a guessing game
where the computer has a secret number
and we are trying to guess that secret
number so the first step is actually
having the computer
generate a secret number for us to guess
and in order to do that we're going to
import
random whenever we call import random it
actually goes to this package that comes
with python
and it says hey all of these functions
that are here
like make these accessible in our script
so that we can call these functions
so for example in order to get a random
number
something like random.rand int might be
very applicable because it returns a
random integer
n such that a is less than or equal to n
less than or equal to b
so a and b are the parameters of this
function and we need to pass in
arguments
i'm going to define a function and i'm
going to define this function
let's say guess i'm going to make
x a parameter so that we can pass that
into
this random getnumber function
so first we need to get the random
number
and our random number well we're going
to use random dot and then rand int
which is exactly
what we saw down here let's make it
between one
and x okay so now basically what this is
going to return
is a random number for us to guess okay
what's our second step here our second
step
is once the computer has a random number
we need to guess right we need to guess
in terminal
and input what our guess of the number
is and the computer will tell us
whether it's too high too low or if
we've guessed the number correctly
i need to keep looping until i get the
right answer
right so that sounds like a job for
loops
and basically since we don't have a
predefined universe to iterate over
we're going to use a while loop so let's
insert
while in there and now in this while
loop
we need an expression here right
and now for this expression when do we
want to stop this loop
we want to stop it when our guess number
equals the random number so that means
our
expression should be something along the
lines of
guess does not equal random number
then we want to iterate over some things
now
we need to actually define this guess
and we're not going to make a guess up
here because we're just trying to
initialize the variable
tell python that this variable exists so
we can go back and change it later
so after a random number i'm going to
say guess equals
zero right because we don't want our
guess to ever
accidentally equal that random number
and here if guess is zero well
random number is random. rand int
between one and
x and that means that it will never
be zero so while the guess is not equal
to random number
we're going to get the user's guess so
guess equals input guess a number
and we can even get a little fancier
here between
one and
so let's use an f string
and we can do x let's just see
what that looks like real fast let's
call our function guess at the bottom of
our script
and then let's just print our guess
let's see what happens when we run this
all right so
if we run this pic guess a number
between one and ten let's do five
okay so we've printed the number right
and i'm just gonna cast this as
integer because i want my guesses to be
integers so what do we have so far the
computer has said
okay i've gotten a random number and now
we've set up this loop
where i can keep guessing until i guess
the right number but that's no fun right
we kind of want the computer to give us
some feedback
give us some clues into what's right and
what's wrong
so that means that i'm going to use some
if statements and these if statements
are going to tell me hey you're kind of
high
kind of low or oh maybe you've gotten it
all right so let's add these if
statements in so if our guess
is less than our random number
then we can print sorry
guess again too low
all right but then else if our guess is
greater than our random number then we
can print
sorry guess again too high
and then if it's not less than if it's
not greater than that means it's
just right it's in that goldilocks zone
right
and that means that you have guessed the
jackpot you have guessed that random
number and so what do we do then
well we actually don't have to do
anything
because remember this loop while the
guess does not equal the random number
it does all of this but as soon as your
guess equals a random number so
once you've input this guess we don't
hit any of these if statements
so then we come back to while the guess
does not equal the number
but now your guess equals the random
number so it actually breaks
out of this loop meaning that at the
very end i can print
yay congrats you have
guessed the number
and you know what we can even just toss
in a random number in there
so let's use our f string again
yay congrats you have guessed the number
random number
correctly all right
are we ready to play so if we go to
terminal
let's run our script okay guess a number
between 1 and 10.
um i'm gonna do four
okay it was too high so maybe two
too low all right so that means if four
is too high if two is too low
it has to be three right
wow look at that i've guessed the number
three
correctly
[Music]
all right so we talked about earlier how
the computer is guessing
our number but we can also do the
complete inverse of that function
we can come up with a secret number and
we can have the computer
try to guess it so now i'm going to
create a new function called computer
guess of x
all right and in this function let's
think about what we actually have to do
so i have a secret number and i'm not
going to tell the computer what the
secret number is right
that basically means the computer has a
range of numbers to work with a minimum
and a maximum
a low and a high okay so that means
let's set the low and the high initially
because
we know what that is without even having
to loop over anything
so i'm going to say low the lower bound
is one
and the high is x because we do have
that entire range between one and x
to work with initially until the user
can provide some feedback
we need to be able to tell the computer
if it's too high too low
or if they've guessed correctly which
means that let's initialize a feedback
variable all right feedback
and at first there aren't any guesses
nothing's too high nothing's too low
so just like how we initialize guess to
be zero let's initialize this to an
empty string
and now basically we want to loop over
this feedback
expression so while this feedback
expression does not
equal what we're going to make it
represent when it's correct
let's do c because c for correct
so while this feedback
does not equal c
well the first thing i need the computer
to do is to guess a new number
so i'm going to make the guess random
i'm going to use random.random
again and this time we're going between
low and high now we don't want it to
always be
between 1 and x right because we want to
be able to kind of change these bounds
according to the user's feedback because
you know that if something is
too high then anything above that we can
kind of stop considering
and then if it's too low anything below
that we can stop considering
so that's why i'm passing in these low
and high values into this rand
in so that we can guess a new number
between the bounds that we
know has to be correct okay
so we have a guess and now we're trying
to ask the user for feedback
hey is our guess right or is it wrong
so here i'm going to do feedback equals
and let's see a user input is
so i'm going to use an f string again so
i can put this variable inside my string
is guess too high
and let's make that h okay too low
and that's going to be l or correct
and that of course is c the user is
going to
input h l or c i have these uppercase
letters here this lowercase up here
i'm just going to make this input
lowercase so
adding that dot lower at the end is
going to take whatever this string is
from the input and just lowercase it so
h
l and c are all lowercase if we try to
compare capitalized letter to its
lowercase letter
it actually does not come out to be
equal so that's why i'm adding this
lower in there
let's look at our different cases again
so if
feedback is h so basically we're saying
okay if it's too
high then that means we want to adjust
our
upper bound because if our guess is too
high like
you know if we're guessing out of 10 and
we guess eight the other person says oh
that's too high that means that
nine and ten cannot be the numbers that
would mean that we need to adjust our
upper bounds
our upper bound is actually going to be
what we just guessed
minus one because for example if we
guess eight then we know it's between
one and seven if
eight is too high and now if the
feedback
is l we know that our low bound has to
be
guess plus one right because it can't be
that low
number and of course we can make that an
l if alif makes it a little bit cleaner
because
feedback can only be h or it can be l
like it can't be both of them
and of course if it's correct we don't
have to have an if statement for that
because our while loop kind of takes
care of that
so at the very end of course when we
exit our while loop that means that
the computer has guessed our number
correctly print
yay the computer guessed
your number
uh let's put the number in there
and so i'm going to put guess in this f
string because
so that means that outside of this for
loop this variable guess is actually the
last thing that the computer had guessed
which means that you know if it's
correct then that is our secret number
all right so basically one other thing
that i've noticed
is random.randam will actually throw an
error
if low and high are the same number
so we can do a couple of things we could
theoretically put this statement up here
that prevents
this loop from continuing if low equals
high because
if low and high are the same number that
means that you've narrowed it down right
if you're saying eight is too low and
your new low is nine and then you're
saying 10 is too high so then your new
high is nine
well that means that the computer has
actually narrowed down the number
to nine but if we break too early so if
we're saying and low does not equal high
then we don't actually iterate over this
loop when our low is nine and our high
is nine right we just break and we say
oh the computer gets your number
correctly but the thing is we actually
want the user
to say that the computer has chosen it
correctly
so that's why we can't actually have
that statement in there instead what we
want is we want to say if low does not
equal
high then our guess is a random number
between low and high
otherwise so this means if low does
equal high
otherwise our guess is equal to one of
them
so let's just say low i mean it doesn't
really matter this could also be high
because
low equal to high all right so then our
feedback
actually puts this number into here and
it prompts the user to say hey that's
that's right
so then at the very end we're saying
okay the computer guessed your number
guess correctly all right let's try this
five oh shoot i need to come uh let's
say our new secret number
is six so that's
too low seven oh that's too high
six okay that's correct yay
and you know we can even play this with
like a thousand
all right so for our secret number let's
actually do the price of ethereum
which is approximately 392.
okay so python 3 main
dot pi 640 that's too
high too low too high
too low too high
close we're getting closer oh 393 that's
a little bit too high
too low 392.
the computer gets our number correctly
look at that the computer has guessed
our number
correctly all right so that's it just
using some functions and some while
loops
we were actually able to get our
computer to
guess our random number and for us to be
able to guess our computer's random
number
so now when we're bored we can play this
guessing game
woohoo
so the next beginner project idea is
rock paper scissors
this one's super simple but it's a step
up from the previous one
here we're going to be using random so
we definitely want to import random
and we're going to be using a function
so basically
we want some user input right because we
want to play against the computer
so the user is going to put in an input
let's use
r for rock p
for paper or s for scissors
and then the the computer is also going
to choose
and here we're going to do random.choice
because we have our three different
choices
rpns so now the computer is going to
randomly choose one of these choices
once we know the user's choice
and the computer's choice we can come up
with some rules in order to determine
who wins
so the first rule is if the user and the
computer
have both the same choice then it's a
tie
in this game we know that rock beats
scissors scissors beats paper
and paper beats rock so let's define a
helper function is win to see who wins
and here i'm going to say player versus
opponent
and this will return true if the player
wins
and now we're just going to use this
little rule that we had
to see so if the player
is rock and the opponent
is scissors or if the player
is scissors and the opponent
paper or so now we have three conditions
right
or the player is paper
and the opponent is rock then we know
that the player has won
so we're going to return true so now
we're going to ask up here if the user
has won
so is when user or computer so the
computer is opponent and the user is a
player
then return you won actually we're gonna
return
it's a tie up here and then otherwise
we're just gonna return you lost because
if the computer won
then we lost here you'll notice that i
don't have an if statement before this
last return
and the reason for that is because if
you've already passed these two cases
and after each of these cases
the function ends right here or in this
case if you won
then it ends right here the only way
that we can ever reach this line
is if we didn't go through any of these
which is the same it just saves you
an extra line of code instead of saying
else
or instead of saying if is when
computer come a user because the only
way we get to this line
is if this is true so we don't even need
that line
so here we're going to print play
and here i'm actually going to add a
line break
and say what's your choice
now let's see what this looks like
what's your choice r for rock paper
paper s for scissors
i think i'm gonna go with scissors
i lost let's play again
rock i won
[Music]
so the first thing that we have to do
for hangman is we have to choose a
random english word
so i actually went on stack overflow and
i found this very relevant
question how to pick a random english
word from a list
and if you scroll down a little bit
there's this like json
file that's linked so i'm just going to
click on that
and when i open it there's all of this
text
and basically what this is is it's just
a
very long list of words that uh
we can use for hangman so i can copy and
paste this entire
list of english words into a python file
and i can assign it to the variable
words which we can use in our hangman
game later
so now i can open a hangman file and i
know that i want to be able to
choose randomly from this word list so
i'm going to import random
and then also i know that um
i want the word list that i just made
and i called my file words.pie
so in my hangman file i'm going to say
from words
which is words.pie import words and
that second word is just this variable
words so now if i print out words
in my hangman file i would be able to
get that entire list of words that i
just copy and pasted
so the first step in actually getting
our computer to play hey man with us
is the computer has to figure out a word
for us to guess
so we just got this entire list of words
into this python file and now we just
have to randomly select a word from it
but you'll notice if you look through
this word list that some of them
actually have spaces
and dashes in the middle of the word
which we can't exactly guess
in python or in hangman
so we actually have to keep choosing a
word until
we get a valid word that we can guess in
hangman
so in order to do that i'm going to
define a function
called get valid word and i'm going to
pass it a list of words
so the first thing i'm going to do is
assign you know
the word to random.choice words
and what random.choice is it takes in a
list and it randomly chooses something
from that list
so i'm just going to get a random word
from this list and i'm going to
make a while loop saying while
dash or space is in this word
keep choosing the word so what this
while loop
does is as long as the statement is true
it just keeps iterating back and forth
until
it's not true anymore which means that
when it stops iterating we'll get a word
that doesn't have a space or a dash in
it
and then finally we're just going to
return that word
we need to be able to keep track of
which letters we've guessed
and which letters in the word we've
correctly guessed
we also need a way to keep track of what
is a valid letter and what is
it so now we're going to set that up i'm
going to have
word letters a variable that saves all
the letters
in a word as a set and this will use as
a way of keeping track of what's already
been guessed
in the word and then i'm going to have
an alphabet
and basically i'm just going to import
this already predetermined list
of like uppercase characters in
the english dictionary um and then
i'm going to have an empty set called
use letters which i will use in order to
keep track of what the user has guessed
all right so now we're going to get some
user input
so basically what we can do is we can
just
ask for user input in python directly
and if we run this in terminal
then the user can type in you know a
character
and we can use that as input
so we're going to save that as a letter
and i'm just going to uppercase this
because i'm just going to do everything
in uppercase
a lowercase a in python is different
than an uppercase a so if you try to
test equality between those two strings
it actually won't be equal so i'm just
going to do everything in uppercase
and basically if i'm going to i'm going
to say
okay if this is already
if this is a valid character in the
alphabet
that i haven't used yet
then i'm going to add this to my use
letters set
and then if the letter that i just
guessed
is in the word then i'm going to remove
that letter
from word letters so every single time i
guess correctly
then this word letters which is keeping
track of all the letters
in a word decreases in size
and then if this user letter that
the user just entered is in used letters
then that means that they've already
used it before and it's an invalid guess
so i'm just going to print
something saying you literally just
guessed that word
or that letter otherwise
that means that you know they typed in
something that's not in the alphabet and
it's not in the
newsletters that they've already guessed
so that just means that they've typed in
a wrong character and we're going to
print an error message saying
you didn't type in a valid character
so now that we can get the user input we
want the user to be able to keep
guessing
until they get the word so in this case
we're going to be using a loop
and loops are basically just a way to
you know loop around your code and
iterate so in this specific case i want
to use a while loop
because i want the user to just to keep
guessing until they actually guess the
word
and because every single time we're
removing a letter
from word letters which is a set of the
letters in the word that we haven't seen
yet
i'm just going to keep decrementing that
so the condition that i have to satisfy
for when the user
gets all the letters in the word is when
the length
of word letters is actually equal to
zero
so while the length of word letters is
greater than zero
i'm going to keep iterating through this
input
until they guess all of the letters
so my while condition is going to be
while the length of word letters is
greater than zero
iterate so let's just add that in there
so before we can actually play this game
of hangman we need two things that we
need to tell the user
so the first thing is what letters
they've already used so that
they can keep track of what they've
already guessed
so we're just gonna have a simple print
statement and then we're gonna
say space dot join
use letters and what this dot join does
is it turns this list into or interval
into a string separated by
whatever the string is before the dot
join so in this case
each of these letters will be in a
string separated by a space
the second thing that we need to do is
we need to tell the
user what the current word is
but with dashes where the characters
that they haven't guessed
are so in this case i'm going to
first create a list where every single
letter that they've guessed is shown
and where all the letters that they
haven't guessed are just
dashes and then i'm going to take that
list
and i'm going to join it with a space
just like above so that we can create a
string
using that list
[Music]
in that game i literally could have
guessed as many times as i wanted to
so let's make this a little bit more fun
let's introduce the concept of lives
into hangman because usually in hangman
you can only guess until the guy is dead
right
so let's say that live let's say you get
six lives
so the first thing we have to do is if
the user
has the letter in word letters then you
want to remove the letter
but if they don't then that's when you
want to take away a life
so with my lives variable which is set
to six at the beginning
i'm just going to subtract one there and
i'm going to tell the user
that your letter user letter is not in
the word
and then everything else should stay the
same now at the very beginning
i'm going to say where the um
where i show the user the letters that
they've already used i'm going i'm just
going to tell them
you have x lives left
and then you know they can guess the
letter and
right now our while loop condition is
set to
as long as they still have to guess more
letters in the word
they keep playing but now we have
another condition right we have the
condition of lives
so as long as either a they haven't won
yet
which is when the length of the word
letters is greater than zero
or b when they haven't died yet
so up here we're going to add another
condition in this while loop
we're going to say while the length of
the word letters is greater than zero
and lives greater than zero
then we want them to be able to guess
this means that
as soon as they either win when they
when they've guessed all the letters
then they exit this while loop or when
they've died when
lives equal zero they exit this while
loop
so at the very end right now we're
telling them that they've guessed the
word
um correctly but now that's not the
condition anymore for this while loop
we also have an aspect of lives so
if the lives equal zero then they
actually
died so we say sorry you died the word
was
blank otherwise in this else statement
we can say
yea you guessed the word so now let's
try a game of hangman with
all these different components
[Music]
now we're going to create a command line
version of tic-tac-toe
with various types of players so either
a human can play
or the computer can play so humans can
play against a computer
humans can play against each other or
the computer can even play against
the computer let's get started we're
going to split up our player and our
game into two separate classes
so that when we actually play we can
create a game and then we can tell the
game
hey this is my x player and this is my o
player
so the first thing we're going to do is
create a file
player.pie and up here i'm just going to
tell you guys right away we're probably
going to need math and random so i'm
just going to import them
right now we're going to have a base
player class and in this class we're
going to initialize it
with the letter that the player is going
to represent
and this is either x or o
so that's cross or not in official like
tic-tac-toe
terms so self-doubt letter is going to
be letter
and we want all players to be able to
get their next move
so here i'm going to say define get move
self comma game and i'm just going to
pass because well this is our base
player class
and on top of that we're going to build
a random computer player
and we're going to build a human player
here we're going to use
inheritance in order to create a random
computer player
and a human computer player that builds
on top of this bass
player object and so in our
initialization we have to initialize
the super class so we're going to say
super.init
letter and what that's going to do is
it's going to call this initialization
in the super class which is
the player and define get
move so in our getmove function
let's hold off on this for now same
thing for
the human player in this human player
our super class is still player
we're going to initialize the same way
that we did the random computer player
and then we're going to find get move
and again self comma game
and let's also come back to this let's
first go
and define the game to see exactly what
we're dealing with when we pass
in the game let's create another file
let's call this one game dot pi so
in game dot pi we're going to define
class tic-tac-toe
and so in this class what are we going
to need we're going to need a board
right because our tic-tac-toe it's a 3x3
board
let's create that board for our board
let's just use
a list of length nine that will
represent
the three by three board and what we can
do is we can assign an index
in this length nine list to each of the
spaces
and then that will represent our board
what i'm also going to do is i'm going
to have this variable self.currentwinner
that will keep track of whether or not
there is a current winner in this game
and if there is
who is it well let's first of all
be able to print the board right we're
going to want to see like
what's in this board so for each row and
here let's split this up into the rows
so self.board this is indexing into our
length nine list and then this i times
three
so we're doing i and range three right
so
this i times three to i plus one times
three
so basically that's saying like which
group of three spaces are we choosing is
it the first one second one or third one
and that
that represents the row indices zero one
two that's the first row
indices three four five that's the
second row and then six seven eight
that's the third row
for each row what we're gonna do is
we're gonna print
and these are just gonna be some
separators so let's add these and then
dot join row is just saying like join
them in a string where the separator
is this vertical line
so you guys don't have to worry too much
about print board because i don't think
it actually
like contributes much to the logic of
the game it's just
how do you print this okay and then
here for print board numbers well this
is a static method because
it's it doesn't relate to any specific
board
we don't have to pass in a self what
this means is we're just going to print
out which numbers correspond to which
spot
and so for example here you can see it's
0 1
2 etc and so our number board is going
to be
string and then whatever i is
for each eye in range again this is a
row
right this number board might seem kind
of scary but
if we think about this for j and range
three so that's j equals zero
one here this range
is j times 3 and then j plus 1 times 3.
so this is the exact same range that we
saw up here for each row so what this is
saying
is essentially just give me
what indices are in the rows for each of
the rows
this is gonna come out to like zero one
two that's
one sub array and then three four five
that's another sub array and then
six seven eight we're gonna concatenate
these strings the same way that we did
above
in print board
okay so now let's actually dig a little
deeper into the logic
of the game given this board we're
representing
the empty spaces with the space we're
going to need to know
what are the available moves after you
make a move right
so we're going to return a list and this
is going to be a list of indices
so let's actually expand this out and
then i'm going to show you guys how to
do the list comprehension for it
let's initialize moves to an empty list
and then let's say for
i comma x and enumerate self.board
enumerate is going to essentially create
a list
and assign tuples that have the index
comma the value at that index so here we
have zero comma
x one comma x and then two comma o
in this for loop we're going through
each of these two bowls
and we're assigning the first item in
the tuple to i the second item
to x so we can say if x equals
actually let's call this spot because
that might be a little bit more
intuitive
if spot equals space then we know that
this is an empty space
and we know this is an available move so
we're going to append
that index because we want to know which
spaces are available we're going to
append the index of that spot
to moves and then at the end we're going
to return moves
another way to write this is a list
comprehension and that would look
something like this
i for i comma spot in enumerate
self dot board if spot
equals space so this is essentially just
condensing this entire
for loop into a single line it's saying
for i comma spot and enumerating the
board
if the spot is space then put i into
this list and then we're going to return
the entire list
easy little one-liner makes the code
clean
okay so now that we have that function
let's define
get move for our players so the square
that we're gonna choose for the random
computer player
well we're literally gonna just choose a
random spot on the board that's empty
so let's just do random.choice which is
going to choose
one thing in a list at random and we're
going to pass in
game which is our board game.available
moves again it's just gonna get a random
valid spot okay so the human player we
want the human to be able to choose a
spot
based on some input that we pass in
through terminal we want the user to
keep iterating until they achieve a
valid square
initially we're gonna say valid square
equals false and then the value is none
because the user hasn't input a value
yet
let's say while not valid square so
while valid square is false
our square is going to be input and then
self.letter so x or o
player turn because we want
the user to actually look at terminal
and not get confused by whose turn it is
and input move zero through nine
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
incorporate a series of checks
to make sure that this is actually a
valid number that
we can put in so here we're going to
wrap it in a tranche
so for the try we're going to say value
so this val
equals int of square remember square is
this input that the user has input
if we can't cast this to an integer if
we can't cast a certain number so
if they input like x y z for square
it's going to raise an error when you
try to cast it to an integer
and then the second part if the value
that they give you
is not in game dot available moves in
the list of available moves
then we can raise a value error
and so essentially if either one of
these things goes wrong
then we know it's not valid right if we
pass both of those and we can say valid
square equals true because
it's valid then we're going to catch
this value error and we're going to say
print invalid square try again
and so this is going to repeat the loop
we're going to get the input for the
square again
and we're going to repeat this checker
at the very end
once we've gotten a valid square we're
gonna return
that value at the end so that's gonna be
the human player's next move
okay so we have our player so let's now
continue working on our game
so that we can start playing a game of
tic-tac-toe
we have part of a representation of a
tic-tac-toe board
let's in order to get the rest of the
functions that we need
let's define a function called play
outside of this class
where we're passing in a game an x
player an o player
and then i'm gonna pass in this extra
variable print game that's just gonna
be set to true or false and if it's true
it'll print out all the steps so this is
like if you want to play against it
but later on if we want the computer to
play against itself or like a bunch of
iterations
we don't need to see the computer print
out every single game so then we can
toggle that to false
if we're printing the game then we're
going to say game dot print board
numbers right because then we can see
which numbers correspond to which spot
and the starting letter let's just
assign that x
i don't know if that's like what
tic-tac-toe actually starts with but
we're just going to say x
all right so now while the game still
has empty squares so
while the game is still like incomplete
we're just going to keep
iterating right and we don't have to
worry about the winner because the
output of this play
let's just return the winner we don't
have to worry about continuing this loop
because
we'll break out of it with that return
statement
so in order to check whether the game
still has empty squares
let's create a function within the class
called
empty squares pass itself and what we're
going to do is we're going to
check if there are any empty squares on
the board so we can just say return
space in self dot board and space and
self dot board
will become a boolean empty squares will
just return a boolean
of whether or not there are empty spaces
in the board
and we might need to know the number of
empty squares
so i'm just going to say okay we can
return the length of available moves
which will return this list and so we
can just count
how many empty spots there are um we
could also
say self.board.com because this is a
list
self.board.count and then just space so
that will count the number of spaces in
the board
all right so while there are empty
squares we want to get the move
from the appropriate player so if the
letter equals o
then we're going to ask the o player to
get move
and if it's not o that means it's x then
we're going to ask the x player to get
the move
all right let's define a function to
actually make a move
now that we've gotten the player to get
their next move
we go back up to our game
and we say define make move when we make
a move we need information about what
square the user wants their move to be
at
and then what letter the player is so we
know like what to assign that square
if the move is valid then we make the
move and then we return true
if it's not a valid move then we return
false nothing should ever be an invalid
move but just in case
if self.board square is empty so if this
this means if at that space on the board
nothing's there yet then we assign that
letter
to that given square and we return true
if that doesn't pass then we return
false
okay so let's put this into our play
loop
so if game dot make move so if this is
valid if we want to print the game we're
going to print
letter makes a move to square blank
and some square let's make an f string
there
and we're going to say game dot print
board because we want to see a new
representation
of the board where this spot has now
been claimed by this
user and here this is just an empty line
that we're gonna print
okay after we made our move
we need to alternate letters so here
we're going to assign letter equal to
o if the old letter was x otherwise
we assign it to x
and this basically a different way to
rewrite this would just be if
letter equals x then the new letter is o
otherwise the new letter is x
that's exactly what we're doing here
we're just switching players
okay but wait we don't we're not
actually checking anywhere
if anybody won so what if we won
if you think about it the only time that
you should win a game is like right
after you make a move right if you
won if you want a game you should win on
that move
so we're gonna go back to make move and
after we've placed the letter
on that board we can toggle current
winner
to the winner if there is one so let's
make another function that will check
for the winner
so after we've made this move if
self.winner
and then we're gonna pass in our last
move because that's the one that's gonna
be our winning move right
if self.winner then we can assign
current winner equal to that letter
we'll come back to the winner function
but
suppose that we have this checker so
then
after making this move if we have a
current winner
we can check for the current winner
before we switch letters and
if there is a current winners which
means which means that if current winner
is not set to none anymore
then a letter has won and we can end the
game because
then we can just return the winner of
the game
so in this game we're going to return
the winner if there is one and if there
isn't then we're going to return none so
that means none is a tie
and we're going to return the letter of
the winner
so here if game.currentwinner
well it was letters turned so we can
just return
letter the letter that gave us the win
okay so then also let's just add in the
nun for a tie right now
so at the bottom we can say if print
game then
after this while loop is over we can
just print it's a tie
all right um now we got to go back and
actually create this function that'll
check
for a winner right so we can define
winner
and then input the square and the letter
and we we know that in tic-tac-toe we're
a winner if there's three in a row
anywhere but we have to check all the
possibilities whether that's in the row
column or the diagonal
all right so first let's check the row
so the row index
which row it's at is going to be
whatever square that you give it
divided by 3 and then round it down
right so that's what this right here is
so that double dash is just saying how
many times is three going to square
row is going to be self.board and here
we're going to see
this indexing again but this is
essentially saying
given the row index get the row so here
row is just going to be
a list of the items in the row that
we've selected
and we can say if all
so this is going to be all is saying
like if everything in this list is true
then this comes out to true otherwise it
comes out to false
so if all and then within this list
we're gonna do another list
comprehension so for every spot in the
row we're checking
whether or not that spot equals the
letter because
that's how we're checking for three in a
row
so if and then if all the things
in this row are equal to that letter so
that means that we have three in a row
in this row then we can return true
if not then we keep going right so then
let's
check the column next and we're going to
use very similar logic so the column
index
is okay divided by 3 and then take the
leftover so that's going to tell us
which column
we were in the column is going to be the
self.board
and here we're going to do another
little indexing trick
but if we take the column index and then
for every single row so that's i for
every single row
if we add the column index and we
essentially get
every single value in that column right
and we're going to put that in a list
and that's going to be
our column so here column is just going
to get everything in the column
where we just moved to and again just
like above we're going to use this if
all checker and instead of row we're
just going to replace it with column
so if everything in the column is
equal to the letter then we return true
okay so now finally if that doesn't come
out to true we're going to check
our diagonals intuitively
we can kind of see that the only way to
win a diagonal is
if you placed a move that was along a
diagonal
here we're going to check if the square
that we had just moved to
is actually an even number zero two four
six eight and these are the only moves
possible because these are the only
these are the diagonal spaces
so if we assign zero one two to the top
row three four five
six seven eight it's pretty easy to see
that the top left is zero
the middle is four and the bottom right
is eight
and then the other diagonal would be two
four and six
so that's why here we're checking if the
square is divisible by two
so that that's basically saying it's
even then this diagonal one
we're gonna say for i and zero four
eight
so this is the top left to bottom right
diagonal so we're going to put the
things in the board that correspond to
zero four and eight
into this diagonal one and then same
thing for diagonal two but instead
it's 2 4 and 6.
so this is the top right to the bottom
left diagonal
and once again we're going to use this
if checker
and say if every single spot equals the
letter in the diagonal
so diagonal 1 return true
and again for this diagonal 2 if
every single spot equals the letter in
diagonal 2 we're going to return true
and at the very end if all of these
checks fail
then we don't have a winner so we return
false
so yeah that's our tic-tac-toe game
right there and so now let's actually
play this game
so if name equals main if name equals
main first we're going to make the x
player equal to
human player and assign it the letter x
so actually at the very top we have to
go back and we have to
import human player and random computer
player from our player file
otherwise this game.pi file has no idea
what's in player.hi
but if we add in this like import at the
top then we actually get our human
player and we get our random computer
player
so for our x player we're going to
create a human player and we're going to
initialize it with the letter
x and then our o player
we're going to make that our random
computer player
and assign that an o and then our game
is gonna be tic-tac-toe let's just call
that t and then we're gonna say t
equals an instance of tic-tac-toe and
we're gonna play
tic-tac-toe so this is a game x player o
player and then we're gonna
set prank game equal to true right here
all right so let's pull up a terminal
and let's play a game so python3 game
dot pi
alright so first i want to move
to four because i want to be in the
middle
okay it's saying it's a tie that's weird
but o makes a move to square
seven let's try to go fix this it's a
tie
so if we go back into our loop we
actually see that print it's a tie is
still within this while loop and that's
not right what we need to do is actually
unindent it to make it fall outside the
while loop so it's only
after there are no more available spots
which means that there is a tie
are we gonna print it's a tie
first we're gonna go again to square
four o is making a move to square
five okay so i actually don't like how
as soon as i said okay go to four
the computers like print out its move
immediately
so what i'm gonna do is during this
while loop so for every single iteration
that we switch on and off
i'm gonna add in a tiny pause
and i can do that by calling time dot
sleep and let's just say 0.8 that's 0.8
seconds
and at the very top we have to import
time in order to make this work
so here we're going to do a little tiny
break
to make things a little bit easier to
read essentially
and let's try writing this again
so we make a move to square four o makes
a move to square six
and let's try the top left so
zero o goes to three and we want that
bottom right so let's do
nine oh
eight we actually have to fix that text
too though
okay so we see that we win though all
right
uh let's go back into the code and it
should actually be
in player.pie here we're just going to
edit this
it's actually zero to eight okay save it
so we were able to actually detect that
it was an invalid square and that we had
to try again
so yeah that is our bare bones
tic-tac-toe
implementation
all right so we created a game of
tic-tac-toe in python
and we created a human player and we
created a random computer player
but can we do better can we make it so
that
the computer literally never loses
maybe ties but never loses
and the answer is yes so let's take a
look
at how we're going to do that
minimax is a decision making algorithm
built off of
a maximizer and minimizer concept
basically you're trying to maximize your
win while your opponent is trying to
minimize their loss
now in a game of tic-tac-toe we can step
through each state
and see how minimax might help us win
and become
victorious in minimax we are trying to
find the best move to make we can
determine this
by trying out all the moves and figuring
out which one is the most
optimal through something called the
utility function
which is basically a measurement of how
valuable the final result
in that tree is now let's take a look at
an example
using a partially completed game of
tic-tac-toe
so in this current board it's x's turn
and obviously the goal is to maximize x
since we want to win
so the first step is to put down an x in
every single possible potential move
you'll notice that in the middle we
actually won the game because we formed
three in a row
now let's talk about this utility
function for a little bit
since we want to win we want our utility
to be positive since this is
a positive value to us now
in addition i have this factor of 3
because i want to win
in as little steps as possible so how i
got this number
is i took the remaining squares on the
board
and added one so that if you did win you
still ended up with a positive value and
not zero
and then i multiplied it by either plus
one or minus one
depending on who the winner was so for
example if
o had actually won in this situation
with
two squares left then i would have done
negative one
times two plus one three which is
negative 3.
so moving on from there we want to map
out all the possible
scenarios of gameplay so continuing this
tree we have this layer
and then this layer until the board is
filled or until somebody
has one now let's add the utility
function for all of these
since o one on the left we're going to
do negative one
times one plus one since there's one
square left
which gives us negative two
in the second one nobody wins and it's a
draw so the value is just zero
now on the right the first one we win
again
but in this case we don't have any empty
squares
so we're just gonna multiply one by one
and then on the right on the far right
it's a draw again so we have a value of
zero
now that we have these utility values we
can propagate them back
up to find the most optimal path to take
so at the very bottom level we have a
maximizer function because it's x's
turn there's actually no decision to be
made in the bottom row because there's
only one option
one path to take
in the second row it's o's turn and we
assume that o will be taking
their most optimal path which means that
we want to minimize
the value that o has and
in this case on the left hand side
it's between negative 2 and 0 and since
negative 2 is less than 0
the left gets assigned a value a utility
value of negative two
the middle is still three because
there's no additional options after that
and on the far right we're choosing
between one and zero
and since zero is less than one the far
right has a utility of zero
in the next stage it's back to x's turn
and we wanna maximize
x between negative two three and zero
obviously three is a maximum so we would
choose that middle path
so now we know what the most optimal
solution is in order to win
in the least number of steps possible
all right so for our implementation we
are going to
create a genius computer player
and this of course is going to take
player as a super class
once again and here we're going to
initialize it the same way we initialize
our other two players
so in our unbeatable computer player we
also
want to get move and get move is where
all the magic is gonna happen at the
very beginning
if all the spaces are available let's
just say
grab a random spot and just go there so
we're just randomly going to choose one
otherwise all right so now we're going
to get the square
based off of the minimax algorithm that
we described
so because of the nature of the
algorithm and how it's recursive
we're going to define a function minimax
outside
of our getmove function but we're going
to call that from here
so self.minimax and we're gonna need to
pass in the game
and the letter of the player so we know
that we can win and not the other
player so at the very end we return the
square that was returned from our
algorithm
and now let's define that algorithm here
so to mini max
and then self comma state
comma player so the reason why i wanted
to call this state
and not game was because at every single
iteration of minimax
we pass in a representation a screenshot
of the game in that state so i'm just
calling it state it's just a variable
name you could call it
s you could call it game you call it
whatever i'm going to call it state
because in my head
we're passing in states we're passing in
screenshots of the game
all right so the max player is going to
be yourself because you want to maximize
your score so it's going to be
self.letter
and then other player is going to be
other players so whatever the letter is
not
so first we want to check if the
previous move is opener
all right so when we have recursion we
always need a base case and this base
case is
well at the very end of things where are
we at
so here we want to see
you know was there a winner in any of
the states that we've passed in
so we know that in our game we have a
current winner so the current winner is
equal to
whatever other player is
then we should return the position and
the score
because we need to keep track of both of
these things for the algorithm to work
so we're going to turn this into
dictionary so the position
is none and the score well
so this is the formula that i was
talking about earlier
we're going to multiply 1 times the
state dot
number of empty squares because we want
to maximize the number of empty squares
we want to get to a win
as soon as possible plus one
if the other player is the max player
right otherwise we're gonna do the exact
same thing
but multiplied by negative one
so else negative one and then state dot
number of empty squares
and then plus one okay so if there's no
winner but if there are empty squares
well that means that nobody's won so our
score is going to be neutral it's going
to be
zero and the position again will be none
because we didn't move
anywhere all right so these are our
base cases all right so now here we're
going to get into the algorithm
so if the player is a max player then
we're going to initialize a variable
best and this is going to be
a dictionary that's going to save the
best position to move
and the best score and because this
player is going to be the max player
yourself
you want to maximize that every single
time step so you're comparing
every single score to this score and
you're trying to increment it so that
means that we want to initialize it
to the lowest possible score so at least
one iteration
will beat that score if we initialize it
to negative infinity
anything that's defined is going to beat
that score
if the player is not the max player then
we want the position to still be
initialized to none
but the score we want initialize to
infinity because we're trying to
minimize
at every single point so we're trying to
decrease that so we have to initialize
to like the highest possible value so
for every single
possible move in the available moves
we're gonna do a few things
so the first step is we're gonna make a
move and we're gonna try that spot
so in step two we're gonna recurse using
mini max
to simulate a game after making that
move so what happens
like from there on if we make that move
all right so step three
we're going to have to undo that move so
that we can try the next one in future
iteration right
the fourth and final step is we need to
update the dictionaries
if necessary so if your score from that
possible move
actually beats the current best score
then we want to replace that dictionary
with whatever we get
from that possible move all right so
let's get into implementing these
so first step one we want to call our
state
dot make move and this is going to be
whatever possible move and the player
that's making that move so player
right and then our simulated score
is going to be well we just made that
move
so now we're going to pass the new state
into mini max
again and so here i'm going to call
self.minimax
state comma and then we're going to
alternate players so it's going to be
the other player
step 3 we undo the move so at that
possible move on the board
we reset it to an empty space and then
we set the state.currentwinner back to
none so this is
undoing whatever move that we just did
and the simulated score
okay so remember that at the very end we
return this position
and then none right so we actually have
to set what position we just moved to
so here our simulated score position
actually equals the possible move that
we've
just passed in otherwise this would kind
of get messed up from like the recursion
part
all right so now in our fourth and final
step we say if the player is a max
player
if the sim score is actually greater
than our best score
then we replace this best dictionary
with the sim score dictionary
otherwise this means that your player is
actually the min player and your sim
score if it's less than your best score
we again replace our best dictionary
with the sim score because we've
successfully gotten
a lower score and so what we're doing is
we're trying to
maximize the max player but minimize the
other player
and at the very very end after we've
tried every single possible step
then our best score this best dictionary
will contain the best next possible move
and the best score that can arise from
it
right it ends up returning a dictionary
of the position
and the score so in order to use that in
our get
move for our genius computer player we
have to actually index
for position and then that'll return the
square the position
where we're actually going to go
oh actually this should be class sorry
that was a little
mistake from my end
all right and now
instead of random computer player let's
try playing against the genius computer
player
and we have to of course import that
let's start a game we're gonna go to the
middle square so
four and we get this error
so let's go back to our code
and where did we call that where is this
error coming from
so we actually see that we're missing an
s right here small little mistake
so let's try rewriting this after we fix
that so four
they go to zero let's go to
the bottom left looks pretty good and
that is square
six so let's go to square six
all right they go to square two so we
gotta block them we gotta go to square
one they kind of forced our hand
one all right they go to seven so this
this is gonna be a tie game right so no
matter where we go
i mean yeah ta-da it's a tie
all right let's try again and i'm going
to show you how this algorithm is
actually going to make a move
cleverly to a spot where like
it'll win so it's i'm just gonna show
you it's gonna go there in the middle so
let's go to the left and see what
happens
so that's square six the algorithm knows
to take that bottom spot to win and here
what we actually can do
is we can set this genius computer
player to play against the random
computer player
and what i'm going to do is actually
print turn print game to false and make
this play
a bunch of times so we're going to keep
track of number of x wins owens
and ties and then we're going to say
like let's run this a thousand times
remember that play passes back whoever
wins right
all right so i'm actually going to put
this time dot sleep and print game
otherwise it's going to be
kind of it's going to slow it down
unnecessarily
so at the very end our result is going
to be whatever
play spits out because that's the winner
so if the result is
x then we're going to increment x wins
plus equals one if the result
is o then we're going to
increment o wins by one
and then now if it's none so that means
x is a win o doesn't win then we're
going to increment ties
by one and then at the very end we're
gonna print like who won what right so
after a thousand iterations we see x
wins
x wins we see o wins
o wins and then we see
ty's number of ties
all right let's try running this
1000 times this actually takes a while
to run
so let's do a little bit of magic
called video editing and bam we see that
after 1000 iterations we see
zero x wins 793 o wins
and 207 ties and you can run this
with the human with the random computer
player as
x or o but if you are playing against a
genius computer player
you will realize that it never loses
it only wins and it only ties but it
never
loses you can run this with like a
million iterations and it will not lose
before we implement binary search let's
actually understand what binary search
is binary search algorithm is a divide
and conquer
algorithm which actually helps you
search
an ordered list faster than just
scanning every single element and asking
hey is this it is this it is this it
and what i mean by divide and conquer is
that binary search essentially works
like this so assume that we have some
list of ordered elements from least to
greatest
and we're trying to see if this target
is in the list and if it is
then return the index of where it is so
essentially we're searching this list
for this target
so what we can do in binary search is we
can go to that middle element
of this list and we can ask hey is the
target equal
less than or greater than this middle
element
if it's equal to then well we've found
it right
but if it's less than then we know that
it actually has to be
on the left side of that element and we
can completely disregard
searching anything greater than that
element so we can completely disregard
the right hand side of that list
and now vice versa if it's greater than
that middle element
then we only have to search the right
half of the list
and now again we can reiterate
on that one section so we divide and
then we conquer that one section
so in that left side let's say that our
target is smaller than
so let's say our target is 7 and 7 is
less than
15. so on that left hand side what we
can do is we can
redo the exact same thing take the
middle of that left-hand side
our target is it less than greater than
or equal to if it's equal to
we're done we've found it if it's less
than again we look at the left-hand side
if it's greater than then we look at the
right-hand side
but up to that middle point where we've
already checked because we're limiting
ourselves
to that left hand side of the array
let's say
that our target is actually greater than
this next middle
and so then we look again on that right
hand side of the array and you can
imagine how with a really really big
array
we keep dividing it in half every single
time
because eventually it'll either be the
midpoint of a bigger array
or we'll come down to like a sub array
of like size
one and then we found our element there
so in this project i'm actually going to
prove
that binary search is faster than naive
search and by naive search i just mean
you're iterating through the entire list
and you're asking hey does this value
equal our target what about here here
here here here and so on and so you're
basically asking every single element
until you hit whatever your target is
so in naive search we're scanning the
entire list asking if it's equal to the
target if it is then we return the index
if not then we return negative one so
let's define naive search
we're going to give it a list l and a
target so for i
and range length l so for every single
index
if l at that index is the target then we
return that index
otherwise we've gone through the entire
list nothing's there
we return negative one
for example our l could be 1 3 10 12
right and if 10 is our target
then we're saying okay for the first i
so if i equal zero our element number is
one that does not equal the target keep
going
so then three this three equal target no
keep going all right so now we're at
index two
okay well ten equals the target so we
return
two and if it's not in there then we
end up returning negative one at the
very end
okay so then binary search uses again
divide and conquer so we will leverage
the fact that our list is
sorted in order to make our search
faster
so let's define binary search and then
give it again
a list l and a target
all right so here i'm going to provide
another example
and i'm actually going to add one more
element in here so it's one longer than
our previous example
so 1 3 5 10 12 and let's say we're
searching for 10 again
and so here we're just saying okay it
should return
3 index 3 because 10 is at index 3.
so the first thing that we have to do is
we have to find our midpoint
so our midpoint is going to be the
length of this list
and then divided by 2 but round it down
and this double dash here this means
this means how many times does two go
into length right
so that's going to give us approximately
the index of the midpoint
so now if l at this midpoint so if this
list at the midpoint is equal to the
target
then we can return that midpoint right
there because that's our index
now if the target is less than the value
at that midpoint
so our target's 10 our value is 5. so
this is comparing 10
less than 5 right which is not true but
if it were again this is saying like
chop off half
of the list and iterate over only one
section of it
so we're going to recurse so we're going
to use binary search again on that one
section that we're given
which here would be one comma three if
this value
if this statement had been true so again
we're going to have to pass in some list
and i'm just going to leave this as
l for now we have to divide it we're not
dividing anything right now
but i'll get back to it so then in the
else statement
well this means that the target has to
be greater than whatever value's at that
midpoint so we only check what's to
the right of it right so then we do
another binary
search all right now these two i told
you guys i would get back to the fact
that we're gonna divide it
in a bit and what we can do is
we could theoretically say okay actually
just pass in that half of the
array so we could index l so that it's
the left or right hand side but then we
just have to add the index
back in another way is that we can add
in
low and high into our binary search and
these are going to be the lowest indices
to the highest indices that we search
and then here when we recurse we can say
the low
is equal to the current low but the new
high
is going to be the midpoint minus
and then for the other side we can say
the low
is now going to be well the next one
after the midpoint
all the way until whatever the original
high value was
and again low and high are indices so
these are all the indices
in our list that we can check and these
are just bounds on the indices
all right so first if low is none then
let's set low to zero because we want
low to be the lowest possible index that
we can check and then high if high is
none
high is going to be the highest possible
index that we can check which is
length l minus 1. all right and then for
our midpoint
instead of just the length of l we're
going to change this to low plus high
because remember this is the lowest
indices plus the highest indices
so the average of those two would be
whatever index is in the middle so
that's our midpoint
how do we know that our target's not
even in the list what we can do is we
can say
all right down here every single time
our target is to the left of the
midpoint
we're actually subtracting one from the
high and then every single time
our target is to the right of the
midpoint we're adding one
to the midpoint for the low so if
the high bound is ever less than the low
bound that should never happen
theoretically if this were
iterated properly the only time is when
it can't find it so the target
is not in the list then we return
negative one so that's our case of
you know it's it's not in this list
all right so if name equals main
then let's create a list 1 3 5 10
12. let's make the target equal to 10
and then let's print naive search of
this list
and then the target and then also binary
search for that
all right opening terminal let's run
this script
and we see both of them return three all
right now let's do
a little bit of timing analysis to show
you guys that
it actually works to not check the
entire list
all right so let's set length to ten
thousand and so here we're going to just
build a random sorted list of length ten
thousand
let's say the values in our sorted list
let's initialize it to a set
first and then while the length of this
set
is less than length well we're going to
add some random integer
and just to have bounds on this let's do
something like
negative 3 times the length of the list
and then all the way till three times
the length of the list so that gives us
a range of like
negative 30 000 to 30 000 for
our algorithm to just choose a random
number and add it into this list
all right so then after this is done
then we're going to say
okay make the sorted list into a list
and then sort it so that's what sorted
is so and then we're going to reassign
this to the variable
sorted list and then we're going to
import time because well we're going to
want to time
how long it takes for each of those
and how we're going to do that is we're
going to say okay start equals time.time
so that gets the time right now
and then we're going to call naive
search on the sorted list
and get some target
and let's actually say let's iterate
through every single item in this list
and try to find that item in the list so
for target in the sorted list so that
means we're going through the entire
sorted list and making everything the
target
and then running naive search on that
one target
so we're basically running naive search
ten thousand times here
and the end time is going to be again
time.time
at that spot and so then the naive
search time
is actually just the end time minus the
start time
and so we can actually do this per
iteration if we
divide it by length so
for each iteration on average it's going
to be n minus start
and then divide that by length number of
seconds
and again we're going to do the exact
same thing for binary search
but make it binary search
so let's run that
okay we see that naive search
takes approximately like .443 like
milliseconds so that's 443 microseconds
whereas binary search i mean it takes
6.8 microseconds so let's compare that
that's like
6.8 compared to 400 something
for a naive search so yeah basically if
you ever have to search a sorted list
never search every single item
i'm gonna be showing you guys how to
build a command line version
of minesweeper that looks something like
[Music]
this
[Applause]
we're going to be using recursion and
classes to build our game
now before we get started i just wanted
to say that i'm building
a very bare bones command line version
of this game
because i believe that when you're
learning how to code
if you actually want to learn how to
translate your ideas and algorithms
into python the bulk of that is going to
be in
actually implementing the game not
figuring out how the ui works i think
that the ui
while it's important it is somewhat
secondary
to actually learning the coding process
and the algorithmic
process that's involved with building
these games
let's start off by defining the play
function
so here our goal of this function is to
play the game so we're going to find
play
pass in a dimension size which is going
to be the size of the board
and the number of bombs on the board
all right so in step one we're going to
create the board
and plant the bombs in step two we're
going to show the user the board and ask
them
where they want to go and now step three
well if the location is a bomb then we
show the game over message because they
just dug
where there was a bomb and but if the
location is not a bomb
then we dig recursively until each
square is at least
next to a bomb right so you think about
how minesweeper works if you dig
somewhere
and it's empty and everything around it
is empty then you keep digging
until you get to a number and that
number represents that that square
is next to a bomb
and then in step four we repeat steps
two and three
until there are no more places to dig
and then we've achieved
victory all right so
right now we're just going to say pass
because we'll get back to this function
okay so let's take advantage of our
object-oriented
programming tools that we have in python
and
let's create a board object to represent
the mind sweeper game
so this is where we can say create a new
object
or dig here or render this game
for this object let's define a class
called board and here we're going to
initialize it with the dimension size
and the number of boards so let's keep
track of these parameters because
they're going to be helpful
later on so let's assign self.dimension
size dim size
to the dimension size that was passed in
and then sell that number of bombs
to the number of bombs that was passed
in
and then we're going to create the board
but let's get back to that
and at the very end we're going to
initialize a set
to keep track of which locations we've
uncovered which locations we've dug
in where the user has gone so self.dog
is going to be
an empty set okay and then let's create
the board
so let's actually use a helper function
so self.board equals self
dot make new boards and here we're going
to plant the bombs too
so let's define that
all right so we're going to find make
new board
pass in self and basically this is going
to construct
a new board based on the dimension size
and the number of bombs
that we pass in and there are a bunch of
different representations that we can
use
so that can be like a list of lists
where each sub list is just
a row of this board so here we're going
to generate a new board this board is
going to equal
it's going to be none and then repeat
that dimension size number of times
because that's how long we want this
list to be
and then we're going to have dimension
size number of these lists so that we
can get
a square board and so this creates an
array that looks something like this
it's just going to be a board where it's
not none etc for our
whatever dimension size that we define
it
so then next we have to plant the bombs
so here we're going to say bombs planted
equals zero
we're just going to use a while loop and
we can say
while bombs planted is less than self
that number bombs
we can pick a random location for the
bomb right so let's actually go up here
and let's
import random and now for the location
we're going to do
random dot rand and somewhere between
zero and self.dimension size squared
minus one
and so you can think about this logic as
like we're literally assigning a number
from zero
you know to the number of spots on the
board and we're assigning each spot on
the board its own unique id
and then this random dot ran in is
returning a random integer
n such that it's between the bounds a
and b so
a would be zero b would be the largest
id
in that list and then here we want to
actually get the row
and the column of that id that we've
chosen
from this random selector so we're gonna
do
the location and then this double slash
self.dim size and what this is gonna do
it's gonna say how many times does my
dimension size
go into whatever location that i've
chosen that's going to be
the row that we're indexing in and then
now
once we have the row how do we know
which column we have to divide
by the dimension size and then whatever
index is left over
that's going to be how far into that
list we have to index in order to find
the column so once we have the row index
and the column index we can index into
the board
and then we can say if bored and then
row
column we're going to index into that
specific row column location on the
board
if it equals a bomb so the star is what
we're going to use to represent the
bombs
then this means that we've actually
planted a bomb there already so we're
not going to increase bombs planted
right instead we're just going to keep
going
and this is actually the reason why i'm
using a while loop and not a for loop
because in a for loop
you know every single time we skip or
like continue
we're still counting that as an
iteration but here
i only want to increment when i actually
get something that's not a bomb yet and
then i plant the bomb
so yeah that's why i'm using a counter
and that's why i'm saying
hey check if this is a bomb if it is
keep going
if not then we're actually going to
plant the bomb and then we're going to
increment this counter bombs planted
and at the very end i'm going to return
the board
all right so that is making our new
board we're going to plant the bombs
right there
all right so what other information is
useful well
we want to know at each spot on this
board
how many bombs are around that spot
that's going to help us when we choose
where to actually
dig right when the user inputs something
well
how do we know where you know whether or
not we should keep digging around it
and yes we can implement a check at each
point where we say like oh
if we dig here we're going to check all
its neighbors and then we're going to
dig again and
you know so on but we could also
just assign values to every single space
on the board that represents
how many bombs are in the neighboring
spaces
so let's call that assign values to
board
so here let's define assigned values to
board and
pass in self
all right so now that we have the bombs
planted we're assigning a number zero
through eight for all the empty spaces
that don't have bombs and this is
basically representing
how many neighboring bombs are there we
can pre-compute these
and it'll save some effort checking
what's around that square
later on basically we want to check
every row
and every column so for r and range
self dot dimension size for c and range
self.dimension size this is going to be
the row index and the column index
so if the item at the board so if
at those indices on the board it's a
bomb
we're going to continue right because we
don't want to actually override
any of the bombs that we've planted
but if it's not then we pass this if
statement and then we say
okay for this location on the board
let's create a new function
called get num neighboring bombs pass in
the row index and the column index and
then this function is going to give us
the number of bombs that is surrounding
that
row comma column all right so let's
define this define
get number of neighboring bombs we're
passing in the rogue
and the column like if you're confused
of why
i have r comma c up top and then row
comma call
these are just variable names you just
have to make sure that they match
where you're actually calling them so
for example when i
call the function i'm passing it r comma
c because i've defined
r and i've defined c in my for loop so
those are variables that i've defined
and now when i create this new function
i can
call the parameters that get passed in
whatever i want right and so here the r
would correspond to the row and the c
would correspond
to the column so now let's iterate
through each of the
neighboring positions and sum up the
number of bombs
so here i've kind of imported a list
of all the neighboring positions you can
see the top left is row minus one column
minus one
and top middle is row minus one column
you know and so on and so we're going to
check all of these
and we have to make sure that we don't
go out of bounds so that's just a little
reminder
okay so first we're going to initialize
the number of neighboring bombs
just to a variable set it to zero this
is going to be our counter
and then we're going to say for r and
range row minus one
row plus one and then keep in mind that
due to the nature of
the range function in python we have to
add a plus one to the end
and then same thing for the column for c
and range column minus one
column plus one plus one
um that should be a plus
all right so basically what we're doing
here is for the current row that we're
at
we're checking below and above and then
for the current column we're checking
to left and to the right and so when we
sum up all these combinations
we get every little piece of the 3x3
grid and then we can say
if r equals the current row that we've
passed in
and if c equals call the column that
we've passed in this is basically saying
like this is our original location we
don't actually have to check this
so we continue but if it's not
if self.board at rc equals a star so
that means
that there is a bomb at that location
that means that we have a neighboring
bomb
right and so we can increment number of
neighboring bombs by one
and then at the very end after we've
gone through all the neighbors we're
just gonna return
the total number of neighboring bombs
now we have to go back up here and we
have to make sure that we don't actually
go out of bounds
right because row what if row is at zero
what if we're checking the first row row
minus one
is gonna be negative one that's out of
bounds here we're gonna add a max
statement just to make sure that
you know row minus one if it ever goes
past negative one we're gonna take
zero every single time we go below that
zero bound
and then for the upper bound we're gonna
do the same thing we're gonna take the
min of row plus one
and then self dot dimension size minus
one because that is the maximum index
that we can go
right
and then of course we're going to use
the exact same logic for the columns
just like this
solve some spacing stuff and so yeah now
we've got our bounds checking and we can
return the number of neighboring bombs
all right let's go back to our play
function now
so step one is creating the board and
planning the bombs
so what we can do is we can say the
board equals an instance of this board
class and then we're going to pass in
the dimension size and the number of
bombs that we've passed into this play
function
and this is going to automatically you
know go through that initialization
function and it's gonna initialize the
board and plant the bombs
and create an empty set for doug and so
on
all right so now part two we're gonna
show the use of the board
and ask where they want to dig and then
we're going to check if the location is
a bomb
is not a bomb we're going to dig
recursively so let's actually go back
and let's implement some of these
functions
so we have them you know handy when we
need them
so let's define a function called dig
within the board class
and we can dig at a certain row and
column index
so we're digging at whatever location
the user has specified
and let's return true if it's a
successful dig
and then a false if we've actually dug a
bomb it's game over and we've lost
so there are a few scenarios here right
either you know we can dig somewhere and
we hit a bomb and then it's game over we
can dig at a location
with neighboring bombs and then you know
we finish the dig because we've
uncovered a number that's not zero
but we might also be digging at a spot
where there
are no neighboring bonds and in that
case we want to dig its neighbors
until we actually get somewhere where
there are neighboring bombs
so the first thing that we want to do
when we dig at a row comma column
is we want to add a tuple to self.doug
to make sure that we're keeping track of
where we've actually dug
and then we're going to check the board
at that row and column so
in our first scenario if it's a bomb we
return false if there's a bomb dog
now if we check that space and you know
it's a number that's greater than zero
that means that
we've dug out a location with
neighboring bombs and we finished the
dig so we just returned true because we
did not dig a bomb
so now if at that row and column on the
board it's not a bomb
it's not a number greater than zero it
means that that spot is equal to zero
right so here we're going to use the
same logic from get number of
neighboring bombs
where we're checking for the neighbors
and let's paste that down here
so here we're going to check r and c for
all the neighbors
and so if r comma c is in self.dog
then we continue because this is
basically saying
you know don't dig where you've already
dug that's pointless right
but after that if it's not then we
dig at that location so we pass an r
comma c into this
dig function again and we continue
through all of this
there shouldn't be a way where we ever
get to a bomb right because we should
always be stopping
at some square right before a bomb so at
the very end
we're gonna return true
so i'm just gonna add one more thing to
this minesweeper game this underscore
underscore string
underscore underscore and so this is a
magic function
where if you call print on this board
it's going to you know it's going to
print out whatever the string
function returns and so here what we're
going to want to do is we're going to
want
to return a string that shows a board to
the player
and i'm going to go over part of this
function but part of it was kind of just
like
like if you inspect the code you'll be
able to tell what we're kind of doing
okay so first we're gonna create a new
array that represents
what the user should see so let's call
this visible board
so visible board is going to be well
first let's just create an
empty board just as we did above so
that's gonna be our list and list
and it's going to be a sub list of size
dimension size and we're going to have
dimension size number of those
lists so now for every single row
and for every single column we're going
to use this for loop again
um if that row comma column
is in self.doug that means the user has
dug at that spot
so visibleboard at that row and that
column is going to be
whatever the actual board value is
but if it's not dug already then this is
actually just going to be a space
because
the user shouldn't be able to see what's
at that location yet
they haven't dug there
and we're going to put this entire board
representation in a string
now what you can do is you can just
honestly return
like a string.join and then just this
visible board
in this code i'm going to make it a
little bit cleaner
and this is all that this stuff here is
doing it's just
some formatting code you can look
through it if you want but
i'm just telling you right now that it's
just completely
formatting to make it look prettier and
to make it print out nice
and honestly i believe that knowing how
to implement minesweeper
is a lot more important to learn than
learning how to print out a
representation of the game
okay so now if we look at steps two
three and four
well step four is basically repeating
steps two and three
until there are no more places to dig so
that kind of sounds like a while loop to
me
right and here what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say
well while the length of
board dug so all the places that you've
dug remember that this is a set
so there are no duplicates while the
length of this set
is less than the board dot dimension
size squared because that's how many
spaces total there are on the board
minus number of bombs then
we're going to allow the user to play
because it means that they still have
empty spaces on the board where they can
dig
that are not bombs so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to
print the board
and we're going to ask the user where
would you like to dig and we're going to
input this
as row comma call so something like 0
comma 3.
and now here i'm going to use a regex
split so that's what re dot split is
it's saying input where would you like
to dig this is going to return a string
and we're going to split that string by
this reg x and so this comma is going to
say okay detect
any commas and then this parentheses
slash slash s well this is saying any
white space so any spaces that you see
and the star at the end is gonna say
zero or more of those
so essentially this is saying match any
part of this string that
matches you know just a comma or a comma
space or a comma space space whatever
the user types
we're going to split that so then we can
handle something like 0
0 zero comma space zero or zero comma
space to say space zero
right and here we have to import r e so
let's go back
to the top and import r e so that we can
split
our string
okay so now that we've split our input
we now know what row and column the user
is trying to dig
so we can assign row and column to the
user input at zero and the user input at
negative one
the reason why we use negative one is
sometimes it's r u dot split it has some
fluff on the inside of this list
and so if we know the row and the column
are at the beginning and the end
then why not just take the first and the
last item in this list
and i'm going to use int because we want
these to be integers
so now let's do some bounce checking if
row is either less than 0
or greater than board.dimension size
or if column is less than 0 greater than
or equal to the dimension size
we're out of bounds so here we're going
to print invalid location
try again and we're going to continue so
that we repeat this loop over again
until the user inputs a valid row and
column
but if the user did input something
valid then we did get that location
so we can call board.dig at row
comma call and so now we've already
implemented this part so we don't have
to actually worry about the
mechanisms of actually digging we know
that
board.dig is going to return true if
we've dug successfully and false
if not and so we can assign a variable
called safe
whether or not our dig was safe so
whether or not we've uncovered a bomb or
not right
so at the very beginning we're actually
going to say safe is true
because at the very beginning we haven't
dug anything you know we're safe we have
all of our lives
and so if not safe anymore
well this means that we've dug a bomb
and
that's bad we're gonna call break
because this means game over
we shouldn't be continuing this loop
anymore we shouldn't be allowing the
user to dig so we're going to break
out of that while loop and now
at the very end there's two ways to exit
this while loop right
either you've won and there's no more
spaces on the board where you can dig
or you've dug a bomb nothing safe
anymore
and yeah rip
so let's check which one if we're still
safe this means that we've just run out
of spaces to dig we've dug
every single possible spot to dig and so
we've actually won let's prank
congratulations
you are victorious
all right but on the other hand if we're
not safe that means
that we've dug a bomb and we can print
sorry
game over
and here we can actually reveal the
whole board
so we're going to assign board to every
single possible value of r comma c
on this board
so this double for loop in this list
comprehension here is just saying
take every single possible r comma c
value of this board and put it in this
list
at the very end we're going to print the
board and so this is going to reveal
every single possible spot
now let's call the play function to
actually play the game
and we're going to put this in a name
equals main if statement because this is
just good practice
it's basically saying like if you have a
massive project but you only want to run
this file
the stuff underneath name equals main
will only run
if you type in python3 mindsweeper.pi
if you have a bunch of imports from a
bunch of other files it's not going to
run any of the code under name equals
main
in those files you're only running
what's under name equals main in that
one file
alright so let's play the game first
let's dig at
i don't know zero zero so here you see
that we've dug at zero zero
it was zero so that means that you know
there were no bombs nearby
and so we kept digging until you know
there were some bombs nearby so for our
next spot let's just do four comma six
and then let's try that bottom right
corner so nine comma nine
and you'll see that this actually
dug a lot so it recursively dug
everything that you see that's zero
it dug until it hit some spot that was
not zero
and if we look at this spot right here
three comma seven
well this is actually you know very
clearly a bomb right so let's dig there
on purpose
so we dug through seven and it says
sorry game over
and it actually reveals that yes
this was a bomb and this was the entire
map of our game
to begin with there you have it a
command line version
of minesweeper
the next project is a sudoku solver in
this tutorial you'll be able to see how
we can use recursion
to solve any valid sudoku puzzle okay so
the first thing that we want to do is we
want to define our function
solve sudoku and we want to pass in our
puzzle
basically this function is going to
solve sudoku using
a backtracking technique so
our puzzle that we pass in is a list of
lists
where each inner list is actually a row
in the sudoku puzzle
so basically this represents the 9x9
puzzle
and we're turning whether or not the
solution exists
but in this code remember how lists are
mutable so we're actually mutating this
puzzle
to be the solution if the solution
exists
so the first step is i'm actually gonna
see where
on the puzzle i can go
so as a human when we're playing sudoku
we typically go from where we have the
most information whether it's
the column that's most filled out or the
row or the little tiny three by three
box
but because we have a computer we don't
have to do that what we can do is we can
assign a number to any open space
on the board and then we can try
essentially every single combination
as long as it's valid and when we see
that
it's not valid we can actually go back
and say oh
let's not try three let's try four
instead and if you think about the
entire puzzle
you can essentially come up with like
every single combination oh
it doesn't work from there okay well
let's take a step back
and try all the combinations there if
none of those work then we take another
step back
and try all the combinations there and
so on and our computer is actually
powerful enough to do that
so that's the technique that we're going
to use here so our first step
is actually to choose somewhere on the
board
to make a guess in order to do this i'm
going to create a helper function
called find next empty and pass in the
puzzle so i can find the open spaces on
the board
so here i'm going to define find next
empty pass in puzzle
and essentially this function is going
to find the next row column on the
puzzle
that's not filled yet and in our puzzle
we're representing any
open spaces with negative ones so we
basically want to return
the next space that equals negative one
so we're going to return the index of
the row so that's
if this is a list of lists the first
index that we return
is the location in that first list
that our empty space is at the second
value that we're returning
is within that row which index is it at
and then of course there might be a
situation where our entire
board is filled and there's no empty
spaces left
in that case we're gonna return a tuple
none
comma none so keep in mind that we're
actually zero indexing so we're starting
from zero
and our last index is eight so
essentially what i can do is i can just
go in order i can say
hey check each row and then check each
column
and whatever the first empty space you
get i'm just going to return the row
comma column
value of that so here i can do for each
row in range nine so i'm iterating
through
my nine rows and then i can say for
that row for each column value
in range nine so that's my zero through
eight
if the puzzle and then here's how we
index we pick out the row
and then within that row we use c to
index again
and get the column so here this double
indexing basically is returning
the item in the arthro and the seath
column and then if that equals negative
one then basically we return
that rc otherwise we return
none comma none if we've iterated
through this entire puzzle
and nothing equals negative one then
that means that there's no spaces in the
puzzle
left so we can return none common none
okay so then the second step from there
is
well if there's nowhere left we're going
to be implementing
some validation checks of like whether
our guess is actually valid or not
and so if we filled out this entire
puzzle then that means
we're actually done so here i'm going to
say if row is none
so remember that above we return none
comma none
and then that first nun gets assigned to
row the second nun gets assigned to
column so we only have to check one of
them
now if row is none then we can return
true because we've actually solved our
puzzle
but if we haven't then we can keep going
all right step two is basically
if there's a place to put our guess
then we want to come up with a guess
between 1
and 9 and we want to actually try all of
them until we find a combination that
works
so i'm going to say for guess in range 1
comma 10.
we start the next step step three which
is checking if this is a valid guess
okay so here i'm going to use another
helper function is valid
and i'm going to pass in the puzzle
guess row
and column because those those are the
key pieces of information that we need
in order to determine whether or not
this guess
at this row and column is valid in our
puzzle so those are the four parameters
that we need
and here i'm going to define the
function is valid and this basically
figures out
whether the guess at that row or column
of the puzzle
is valid and so if there's no conflicts
then we consider it valid and then
we return true we return false if it's
not
so now we have to follow sudoku rules if
our guess equals anything that exists in
that row
or the column already or even the little
three by three matrix that it's in
then it's not valid so let's actually
start with the row because that one's
the easy one right
every single list within our puzzle
represents a row
so if we have the row index then we can
just say that the row values are equal
to the puzzle
index at the row so if our guess is in
row values
then we can return false all right now
the columns
the columns are a little bit trickier
because we actually vary
which row we're indexing into but we
index at the same spot within each row
so what we can do is we can create a new
list called column values and we can say
for each row i mean i can say for i
enrage nine
so that will go through all the rows i'm
going to append
the value at puzzle at the i throw
at the call column and so another way to
write this actually is using a list
comprehension where i can say
take puzzle and then index into i and
then within that row index into call
and then do that for i in range nine
and then that's essentially going to
build the exact same list
so then if the guess is in those values
then we return false because it means
that it's in our column
and then now this the little three by
three square matrix so this part's a
little bit trickier because we actually
have to figure out
where in the 3x3 grid we are
and so to do this what we're going to do
is we're going to find
the starting index of the row of that
by three matrix and then we're gonna
find the starting column
index of that three by three matrix
and then we're gonna say for each row
for each of the columns within that
three
we're gonna iterate
so what we can do in order to find this
is actually take the row
index and divide it by three
but throw away the remainder what is
like
for example if i have 1 divided by 3
that comes out to 0.333 so
the base or whatever you want to call it
is 0.
and then 5 divided by 3 well the
remainder is 2 but 3 goes into 5 one
time
so i'm going to return one so then i can
take that and i can figure out if it's
in the first
set of three rows the second set of
three rows or the third set of three
rows and then of course in order to get
like the actual index of that i have to
multiply that value by three and then
it's the exact same logic for the
columns so when i get row start i'm
trying to get the start value of these
chunks
right but then when i'm getting the
column i'm getting the start value of
these
chunks maybe it's the other way around
on youtube
when i have both of the starts i can say
hey now we're going to iterate
through this so i can say for r and
range
row start comma row start plus 3 because
we want to iterate through the three
rows
for c in range call start to call start
plus three because we want to iterate
through
three columns if the value
at the puzzle equals our guess so that
means our guess is already in this three
by three matrix
so we just have to return false
and now at the very end if we've passed
all of these checks and we haven't
returned false yet
that means that well it is valid and we
can return true
all right so let's close those functions
okay now back to our sudoku code
so if is valid is true then
we want to actually place that guess on
the puzzle
at that row comma column
so what we can do is we can say puzzle
index at the row
index at the column is now equal to our
guess
so we're actually mutating this puzzle
array
so now in step four we're going to
recursively call our function
because if i guess one number then that
number is actually mutated
in my list of lists and i can pass that
in
as my puzzle and then the next value
becomes mutated and then so on
until we reach the very end so that's
essentially what we're doing here
we're just solving this entire thing
with this new guess in our array
so if that comes out as true then we
know that we've actually solved our
sudoku puzzle
so we can return true
but of course there's also the case
where
where this is valid check might not be
valid
and there's also this case of well what
if
we didn't solve the sudoku when we tried
that guess
in the row and column
so then in this case we actually need to
backtrack we need to say
hey so this guess was wrong let's reset
it
and move on to the next guess so here
i'm going to say puzzle row call
equals negative one because we didn't
successfully place anything there
so we're essentially just resetting the
value at this row
and column and now you can imagine this
for loop is going to go
over you know all the possible values
one two three four five six seven eight
nine for every single empty spot along
this entire
puzzle right so that means we're
literally trying
every single possible combination for
the sudoku
so in our last step if we've tried every
single combination possible
and none of them work then that means
that we actually can't find a solution
so this puzzle is unsolvable
and then we're going to return false
all right so let's actually test this to
prove that it works
okay so python 3 sudoku.pi
we see that it comes out as true and
this is our board
so let's try resizing this to see if we
can like
actually view this as a board okay there
we go let's do a couple of checks just
to make sure that like
our solution is actually true so in this
first
box up here let's do one two three four
five
six seven eight nine all right and then
this column we have one two
three four five six seven eight nine
in this row one two three four five six
seven eight nine okay so that's pretty
convincing that like this is actually a
good solution
okay so a couple of notes about my
implementation
recursion is confusing recursion kind of
makes your brain hurt
i think it might be better understood
this way think about solve sudoku
as a black box it should be able to
mutate the input puzzle so that it's a
solution
if it's a valid input puzzle now if it's
not a valid input puzzle
well then it should be able to identify
that because we've tried every single
combination
for that puzzle so when we make a new
guess
we can pass this new guess as a puzzle
into our solve sudoku function and if
it's solvable
then we know that our guess was the
correct guess and we've actually reached
a solution
now if it's not solvable well then we
know that that guess that we passed in
it's not a solvable sudoku solution so
we can say okay that wasn't the right
guess so now let's move on to the next
one
and this is how we kind of go through
this entire puzzle and mutate
the sudoku array that we originally pass
in to be the correct answer
i hope that clears things up for you
guys
this next project is going to deal with
editing images
in python i've prepared some starter
code if you go to
this link down below the one that's for
pi photoshop
you can click this download code you can
either download the zip file or you can
get clone it if you know how to do that
and let's take a look at what's in this
code
so here i've prepared for you a lake
and a city image and so we're going to
actually be editing
these images and doing like cool things
on those
using python
so in the png.pi file
this is some code that johann
roshol put together and i just copy and
pasted this from online
essentially what it is is it's a png
reader and a writer
and what that means is well the writer
is a png
encoder in python and then the reader
is a png decoder in python so it takes a
png image
and it decodes it into like a python
array
and vice versa for the writer it takes a
python array
and it writes it to a png file pretty
cool
all right so now in this image class
this is some code that i've prepared for
you
and we can see in this initialization
you can either initialize it with x
pixels y pixels and num channels
and that will initialize to an empty
array of zeros
or you can import a file and this image
will represent whatever file that you've
imported
so here we have the input path and the
output path these are just the folders
for
the inputs and the outputs and
here we have a checker to see if the
user has actually passed in
x pixels y pixels and num channels
so if it has we assign those values and
then we create an
empty array essentially by the way
number of channels just means
like for example typically when we work
with images we work with
rgb channels so that's red green and
blue
and so that's three channels that's what
we're going to be using today and then x
pixels and y pixels
will describe the size the actual
physical size of the image
so here we're initializing these to all
zero and this is going to be
a numpy array of the size
x pixels y pixels num channels so you
can think of this command as kind of
just creating a three-dimensional matrix
with dimensions x pixels y pixels num
channels
and it's initialized to all zero that's
essentially what self dot array is
initialized to
when you pass in x pixels y pixels and
num channels
so if there is a file name then we
actually read that image from
this helper function read image and set
that to the array
and then x pixels y pixels and num
channels will set to that array
dot shape at the very end we're going to
add this else statement
because if the user hasn't passed in x y
and num
channels or if they haven't passed in
file name then we're actually going to
raise a value error saying
you have to input one of those options
okay so let's go over
the read image function so read image
you have to
pass in a file name and this gamma you
don't have to worry too much about that
it's just a way
to encode and decode it so that your
operations are not exactly linear
and so here i'm using png reader this is
from the png file
and i'm passing in the file name i'm
gonna read it as a float
and then here we're just gonna do a
bunch of like resizing things
i mean i've given you guys these
functions for a reason it's because
i don't think that they're critical in
understanding how the actual
photo manipulation works so then in this
right image
so this function call will write
whatever this image represents
to a png file and we're clipping it
to between zero and one the reason for
that is because
when we transform it back into the
output file
we're going to scale everything from 0
to 255
and so we're going to do a little bit of
reshaping
and write it out to the output file
using the png
writer and we're going to resize this
array because we did a little bit of
reshaping but we want to keep it
in the same representation right we
don't want to actually mutate
our representation of the array so down
here
we're just going to do a quick test to
see that this
like import and export works so
we're going to call image equals image
dot file name and
let's use the link and all we're going
to do is we're going to write to the
output file
we're going to write image test.png and
what we should see
is that test.png should be identical to
lake.png because we haven't manipulated
the array at all so let's try that
okay so test.png this is
the same image and so where the bulk of
our
code is going to be is in this
transform.pi
file we're going to implement a couple
of things here the first thing that
we're going to implement
is adjust brightness so
how do we adjust the brightness here
basically when we adjust the brightness
we want to scale each value of the pixel
by some amount factor
that's a value greater than zero it's
basically how much you want to brighten
or darken the image by
if the factor is less than one then
we're darkening and if it's greater than
one
then we're brightening so first we have
to figure out
how big exactly this image is so that we
can iterate through
each pixel and so first we get
image.array.shape because remember that
we've stored
our values in self.array for that image
all right so basically
we're getting the x y pixels and then
we're getting
the channels okay
and then basically we're gonna make an
empty image so that we don't actually
mutate this one that we're passing in
so this new image is going to be x
pixels equals
x pixels y pixels equals y pixels
and then num channels equals num
channels
so it's gonna be the exact same size of
the array that we pass in
but now we're just gonna be mutating
this new image
so we don't change the original one this
is
maybe the most intuitive way to do this
it's non-vectorized if you don't know
what that means
don't worry about it i'll show you in a
bit but essentially we're going to
iterate for every single
pixel and x pixels for every single y
pixel
and then for every single value of the
channel so literally you can
imagine this 3d matrix and you're
iterating through each
individual value and then for that value
well we have to adjust the brightness by
some factor so we're going to say
new image and we're going to take the
array and then we're going to
index into whatever position that we're
currently at so
x y c so at
index x y c we're going to set this
equal
to our original image that array at x y
c so that corresponding pixel
and then multiply that by the factor
that the user has
input and then at the very end we're
just going to return the new
image so let's actually try this first
see that it works
here at the very bottom i've provided
already
a little bit of code that tells you all
right load the lake
and load the city so let's
lighten the lake for example
so let's say brand m equals adjust
brightness lake and then some factor
greater than one so let's just do
1.7 and then we're going to write this
image to
brightoned.png so
let's try that so python3 transform.pi
and we get this image that's slightly
brighter
we can compare this to the lake if we
move
these side by side you'll notice that
the brighten one is like
slightly brighter
so let's actually try also darkening so
darken image equals
adjust brightness and then let's make
the factor 0.3
and let's save this as darkened
and now writing that again
alright we get the darkened image here
so we can tell that this is darkened
from
our original image and let's compare
these side by side again
right so the darkened image does look
darker
okay so i mentioned earlier that this is
a non-vectorized
way to do it and this is because
this is the most intuitive like this is
behind the scenes
if you are brightening or darkening
something you have to adjust every
single pixel value and increase or
decrease it
all right so one faster way to do it is
the vectorized version
so we said before that these are numpy
arrays but the strength of
this such array is that okay it's numpy
but i've always read it as numpy
but basically the strength of this array
is that you can vectorize these
operations so if you want to add a
constant if you want to multiply by some
scaling factor
you can directly just call that array
and then times that
factor it's significantly faster than
iterating through
using a for loop and we can see that
this does the exact same thing
if we just let it run on the darkened
image so let's
do darken image two let's call the
transform
all right we get the starkit image two
and this looks
the exact same as our darkened image
let's move on okay we're going to adjust
the contrast
now so when we adjust the contrast we're
going to be
doing the same thing where we want to
create a new image
copies so that we can put new values in
without modifying the original
image we're going to be repeating this
for x
y and c thing because even if you can
vectorize things i i like this way of
just showing you guys what's like
actually going
on here we're going to index at
xyz that position again in the array of
the new image
so what adjust contrast does is it
adjusts the contrast
by increasing the difference from the
user-defined midpoint by some amount
factor so essentially if your point is
above
the factor then you take that difference
you scale it by factor
and then you add back whatever the
midpoint was same thing for the other
side
so basically what you're doing is given
this midpoint you're making the
difference from the midpoint
greater so we're going to take the
image.array
and we're going to take the value at x
comma y comma c subtract out the
midpoint
and then scale that by the factor factor
and then we're going to add the midpoint
back in
all right and then of course we return
that new image and just to show you guys
what the vectorized
version would look like it's just new
image.array
equals the image.array minus mid which
is a constant so
it's taking that entire array
subtracting this mid from every single
value in that array
scaling that entire array by factor and
then adding back
a constant mid so it's literally taking
every single
item in that array and adding the
midpoint back in
all right so now let's try adjusting the
contrast
of this like image so let's do
increase contrast equals adjust contrast
lake
2 because remember the the higher
the scaling is the more the contrast we
have right and let's do
the midpoint 0.5 because we're working
on a scale of zero to one for these
images
and now we're going to write the image
let's call it increasedcontrast.png
and i'm going to do the same thing but
let's decrease
the contrast now
so i'm just going to do the same thing
except instead of 2 i'm going to pass in
scaling factor
0.5 and here let's just call this
decrease contrast
and we're going to write this to
decreasedcontrast.png
let's run this
okay so let's compare these so
this is our original and then this is a
decrease contrast so you can see that
it's significantly grayer and this gray
just means that the contrast has
decreased and everything's closer to
being the same color
which just happens to be gray and now
this is the increased contrast you can
tell
that like i mean the contrast has really
been increased
the colors are a lot more drastic in
this one right
okay so the next thing that we're going
to implement is
a blur for the image so in the blur we
pass
in a kernel size and this
kernel size just means how wide do you
want this blur to be because essentially
what we're doing when we're blurring
is we're taking that pixel and averaging
it with its surrounding pixels
and so if the kernel size is for example
three
then that just means we're taking a
pixel and we're applying
this kernel around it so it should be
taking
the left and the right neighbors and top
and bottom
the four diagonal corners for example a
kernel size
of 15 would take the 7 to the left the
seven to the right
and the seven to the top and bottom and
everything in that square
all right so once again we are going to
create a new image to make a copy to
and we're just going to use a naive
implementation of
iterating through each neighbor and then
taking the average
at the end there is a faster way to do
it
but this again is more straightforward
to understand it's more straightforward
to figure out what we're doing
the faster way to do it would be to
incorporate some sort of
like memoization which means so for
example what we would do
is we would move like along the x-axis
and every single time instead of
re-summing every single neighbor
we just get rid of one column and then
we add in the next column and so on and
that would
decrease the number of operations that
we actually need
but again this is more straightforward
so we're gonna use this way for now
first we're gonna create a variable
total equals zero and this is going to
keep track
of what the total of all the summations
of the surrounding pixels are
and of course we need to know how many
neighbors we actually have to
go for so we're gonna find neighbor
range as
how many times does two go into the
kernel so how many neighbors
to one side do we need to look at
essentially is what this represents
and here we're gonna say for each x i
in the range x
minus neighbor range to x plus
neighbor range and remember that
we have to add this plus one because
range
goes from the lowest to the highest
minus one right that's just how python
works
it doesn't include the end of the range
so you may think that
this is all good to go but what if
x minus neighbor range is actually less
than zero
then it would go out of bounds so here
we're going to add a little bit of
bounds checking so we're going to say
take the max
of x minus neighbor range or zero so for
example if x minus negative range is
negative then we would say okay no cut
it off at zero
and same thing for x plus neighbor range
we want this to be the minimum
of the maximum value that we can take
which would be x pixels
minus one and the reason why we do minus
one is because
x pixels is the length right and we have
to subtract the one
because that's the highest possible
value that we can actually index
into remember that python we do zero
indexing
so then again we're gonna do the same
thing for the y neighbors
and we're gonna keep these bounds
because they are the same but instead of
x pixels we do y pixels
and then we do y plus the neighbor range
every single time we go through a new
neighbor
we to add that value from the past and
image to our total
and then at the very end we can say our
new image
at that specific index is equal to the
total
and then divided by the total size of
the kernel so how many things did you
just sum over
we have essentially a box of size nine
right
nine elements in that box so we have to
square
our kernel size and then divide our
total by that
and so that just gives us the average
value over that pixel and its neighbors
and then we return this new image
okay so i'm actually gonna run this blur
on the city because the city
it has more lines in it it's more
obvious if it's blurred
so let's do a blur with size three blur
three equals blur
city comma three and then we're gonna
write image and call it blur k3
and now i'm going to do the same thing
with a kernel size of 15 just so that i
can show you guys the difference between
using a kernel size 3 for a blur and
using a kernel size 15
for a blur so let's run that
okay so our blur of three is done and
you can see that
it looks slightly blurred
when you compare it to the original so
our blur we know that our blur is doing
the job
and it's still running for the 15. again
this is not the fastest way to do it
and the higher your kernel size is the
slower the more this is going to make a
difference
it looks like r15 is now done
okay so let's open that and now we see
that this is like
noticeably much more blurred than our
original
and the reason is literally just because
we've taken more pixels into account
when we've created this average for that
one new pixel spot
okay so actually this blur that we've
implemented above
we've actually implemented applying a
kernel to an image
and so what that means is we're taking a
matrix and we're applying it to every
single pixel
and summing up whatever values in that
matrix times whatever value is at the
corresponding pixel
so in this blur above it's a kernel of
size
and by n and each value is actually
1 over n squared all right
let's see how we can create a function
apply kernel
so we can take in any kernel and we can
apply it to our image
so we're going to assume that the kernel
is square first thing that we're going
to do
is we are going to again paste the code
that we had above
and here our kernel size is slightly
different because we're not passing that
in instead we have a 2d numpy
numpy 2d numpy array that represents the
kernel that we'll use
the kernel size is just one dimension of
the kernel
2d array so we can just say kernel.shape
0 we're going to keep this iteration
through the neighbor range
and so here we need to actually find
what value of the kernel corresponds
to that pixel that we're at so x k is
actually whatever x i we're at
which is representing you know x minus
that neighbor range right
so we're actually going to add that
neighbor range back in
and subtract x and you'll see that what
this does
is essentially it's centered around x y
right so at x y that would be the center
of the entire kernel
but now we're trying to shift the zero
for example
up to the top left corner so that's
that's what that those are the
operations that we're doing here
if you draw it out it makes a lot more
sense
all right and then for y we're doing
what i i plus the neighbor range
and then subtracting y from it
okay so then the value at the kernel
would be
kernel and then indexed at x k and y k
and we add to our total this variable
total
we add the image at that
index x i y i c
but then we multiply it by the kernel
value from our kernel
and so then the new image that array is
xyc
and that is equal to whatever the sum of
all of these are
and then of course we're going to return
the new image
so let us
so i'm gonna so i'm gonna show this to
you guys on an edge detection kernel
it's called the sobel kernel so
in the x direction it's going to be this
array
one two one zero zero zero negative one
negative two negative one and this y
kernel will be the same
except there will be some values that
are switched so
i can write this in a 3d format that's a
little bit easier to see
and so we're applying this over every
single pixel in our image
and now here's the y's
all right so you see these are almost
the same thing right
let's apply this kernel to the city
so let's call that symbol x apply kernel
city
and then syllable external and then
we're going to write this
to edge x dot png we're going to do the
exact same thing for the y
kernel and now you'll see why i call
these
x and y so let's run this
we go here and we look at
the city on one side and now let's look
at this
edge x so you can see that this edge x
really like i mean look at that
horizontal
line right there it's an x edge
detection filter
and now let's take a look at edge y
so you can see how this one really
highlights the y edges right
the edges in the y direction
it would be really cool if we could just
put these together and create an edge
detection
filter and that's exactly what we're
going to do next we're going to combine
these
make an edge detection filter for our
image so
here we're going to combine images image
1 and image 2.
so one thing here is the size of image 1
and the size of image 2 have to be the
exact same thing the arrays have to be
the exact same
dimensions and we're gonna
again copy this shape and create a new
image
and we don't need any of that kernel
stuff but basically what we're gonna do
is we're gonna take
the value from image one square it the
value from image two
square it add these two together and
then take the square root of the sum
we have x y and z and index at the new
image
is going to be it's going to be whatever
is at that index in image 1
squared plus whatever is at that index
in image 2
squared and then the entire quantity
square rooted
so this to the power of one half is just
square root and
at the end we're going to return new
image
and up here we are getting an error
because this should actually be
image one or image two it doesn't matter
they should be the same shape right we
said that
like when we defined the function let's
try it on
sobel x and y so uncomment some of this
stuff
and at the very end we're going to do
sobel x y equals combine images
syllable x and syllable
y and so then syllable x y
dot write image and let's call this
edgexy.png
alrighty so let's run this
so let's set all of these next to each
other so on the bottom right we have the
original
image then we have the x and the y
filters and now check this out so this
is the images combined the filters
combined and you can see that this is
a pretty cool edge detection filter
and let me try to actually like zoom in
make this a bigger image
so this is our image and check that out
i mean you see all the edges in the
image basically
pretty cool look at that skyline
and so yeah using all of these
techniques you could literally
implement photoshop in python
pretty cool
so the last project i have for you guys
is what i call
graph composer and it's kind of like an
introduction
to ai the idea of graph composer
is derived from a markov chain and so in
a markov chain you have a node that
represents a value
and it has an arrow pointing to maybe
another node that represents another
value
and that one might be pointing to
another node which might point back to
the first one
and so on so you kind of create this
entire network
of nodes and directed edges with weights
in our graph composer what we're going
to do is we're going to take a text file
and we're going to transform every
single word in that text file
to a node and then we're going to
connect it
to whatever words follow that specific
word so here's a little snippet about
how these markov chain
graph models actually work given a text
i can generate a graph from the text
where all of the words are represented
by vertices
and then there's a directed edge from
each word to the word
that follows in the text now the weight
of the edge would just be the number of
times that the new word
follows the word that you just connected
it to so
let's take an example sentence how about
i am subscribed to y
cubed and i am loving it so here we can
take the letter i
and we can make it a vertex and now we
can connect an edge with weight
1 to am because am follows i
one time so far and then subscribed we
are connecting subscribe to am
with the directed edge of weight one two
y
cubed and okay so now things get a
little bit interesting because
after this last and it goes back to i we
already have a vertex representing the
word i
on our graph and so and is going to
connect directly to that vertex that's
already in the graph
okay but then we have another occurrence
of i am
so instead of creating another vertex
for am
we're gonna increase the value the
weight of that
edge that's currently there so instead
of one
we're turning that into two and then we
can continue on
so am is already connected to subscribed
but now loving also follows am
so we're going to create a new vertex
for the word loving
and assign that a new edge with weight 1
and then of course
it and now it gets connected to loving
so this would be the graph that
represents a sentence
i am subscribed to y cubed and i am
loving it so with all the songs of an
artist that i've chosen
i have basically created this like huge
graph of
all the words as vertices and edges
connecting them to the words that follow
okay so now in order to generate my
poetry
i can randomly choose a starting word
by randomly choosing a starting vertex
and then i can traverse the graph
based on the edges so these edges are
kind of rules for
which word you can go to next you can
only follow the arrows
so here's an example of what i mean by
that let's take the graph that we just
saw
and let's say that our starting word is
y
so i'm at y there's only one arrow out
and it's the cube so my generating thing
is going to be y
cubed and because and is the only word
that follows cubed
and then of course i because i is the
only thing that follows and
and then am right so y cubed
and i am well now we have two arrows out
of am we have an arrow to subscribe
and an arrow to loving we can actually
choose either of these paths and in my
script i've left that
up to randomness so that's where these
weights come into play these edge
weights come into
play the higher weighted an edge is the
more likely
that path will get chosen and this is
how i can generate
these sentences all stitched together
i'm going to show you guys how to
actually implement this
in python first thing that we're going
to do is we're going to go to
this code that i've already prepared for
you what you can do here
is you can download the code over here
you can download as a zip file or if you
know how to get clone
go ahead and do that let's take a look
at what's actually in these files here
i have two empty files compose up high
and graph.pi
under songs i have well i have a bunch
of text files that represent
song lyrics and we'll get to those a
little bit later but basically we can
generate lyrics using our little markov
chain model i also have
under texts this harry potter sorcerer's
stone
text file and so we'll be able to see
how we can actually generate some text
based off of harry potter as well and
in lyrics.pie you guys don't really have
to worry about this this is just a
scraper
that you know you input some songs and
then the artist name
and it'll scrape lyrics genius
for those lyrics basically it'll
download those lyrics and save it in the
files that you guys saw before
so graph.pi and compose.pi are empty
because well those are the things that
i'm going to show you guys
how to implement let's start with
graph.pi also guys just letting you know
that in this tutorial
i will make mistakes i wanted to show
you guys this because i wanted to let
you know that it is very
very normal to have bugs in your code
it's very normal to make mistakes
and the important part is to actually
know how to fix them
so just keep that in mind while you're
watching this tutorial
okay so in graph.pi this is where we're
actually going to have our markov chain
representation
and you know we know that in this markov
chain we're probably going to need
randomness
so let's import random right now we're
going to define the graph
in terms of vertices naturally let's
create a class called
vertex first thing that we're going to
do we're going to initialize it so
define
init and we pass in a value now this
value is going to represent
our word from the text here we can set
self.value
equals value so whatever the
vertex.value is that's just going to be
the value that's going to be the word
that it represents
and here i'm going to have a dictionary
called adjacent
and what this adjacent dictionary is
going to do it's going to keep track of
you know which vertices
are connected to this vertex and so
those are going to be our keys
and then the value of that
node is going to be our weight the
weight of the edge from
our current vertex to the adjacent one
let's create a function called
add edge 2 and so we have to pass in a
vertex because we need to know which
vertex we're drawing the edge to
and let's create a weight of zero we can
allow the user to manipulate the weight
so let's pass in the weight
but you know we can set it to zero
initially just in case they don't want
to pass in anything right
what we're going to do is we're going to
put this vertex in the adjacent
dictionary
and the value is again going to be the
weight so this is all we have to do
every single time we're parsing our text
whenever we see
a word go to another word that's already
in it's adjacent
what we want to do is we want to
increment that edge right
so here we pass in the vertex and then
we can say self
adjacent vertex equals self.adjacent.get
vertex comma 0. and so this dot get is
just saying
if this vertex is a key that's currently
in self.adjacent
we're going to get the value of that
vertex if it's
if it doesn't exist then we're just
gonna default make it zero
and then we add one and so this add edge
two
is basically adding an edge to the
vertex that we're inputting
with some weight whereas this increment
edge we're
incrementing the weight of the edge from
our current vertex
to whatever vertex that we give it all
right now that we have
a bit of our vertex representation we
can put this together
in a graph so let's create another class
called
graph and we're going to of course
initialize this and we're just going to
initialize this to an empty dictionary
of vertices
and the reason why we do that is so that
whenever we encounter a new word we can
look it up in this dictionary and then
get the vertex
object from this dictionary so this is
going to be a string
to vertex mapping
all right so let's define a function get
vertex values
and this is basically saying like what
are the values of all the vertices
in other words let's just return all the
possible words that we have
in the graph so what we can do is we can
return the set of self.vertices.keys and
this is just going to return
all the words that we've encountered so
far
and then we can create a function to add
a vertex into our graph so like for
example whenever we encounter a new word
we want to add a vertex so when we
create a vertex we of course have to
pass in
a value that's going to be the word that
it represents
we're going to do self dot vertices
value equals
vertex of that value so we create a new
vertex object
and we're putting it in this string to
vertex
mapping and of course we want to define
get vertex because sometimes we'll just
have a word
and we want to get the vertex object
that it represents
so if we pass in the text the word value
well okay we want to return
self.vertices and then whatever
is at that value right because in this
dictionary we're mapping it to
the vertex and returning that object but
what if the value
isn't actually in the graph so in that
case
what we want to do is we want to
actually add it in because if we're
asking get vertex of that value well
it doesn't hurt to ever add it so if the
value is not in self.vertices
we're going to add we're going to call
self.advertx
that value we're just going to create a
new vertex for that value
and then of course return it afterwards
and the most powerful part of this
markov chain
is that when you're at a node you can
say okay get next word
but based on these weight mappings here
we can create
a function called get next word and pass
in the current vertex
and what it's going to do it's going to
first find whatever
vertex object corresponds to that
current vertex
so we can say self dot vertices and then
the current vertex dot value
and now let's create a function called
next word under this vertex
object and what we're going to do is
we're going to randomly select a next
word
but based on weights
all right so if we actually go to look
at the random
documentation we see that there's this
function called random.choices where you
pass in a list
give it some weights and it'll actually
choose
randomly but based on the weights so
we're going to use that idea here
let's return random.choices
and pass in self
okay but then how do we know what do we
even pass in right
let's introduce this concept of a
probability map
we're going to map each word to its
probability but put them in separate
lists
all right in this function for each
vertex comma weight
in self.adjason.items remember that
self.adjacent
is this dictionary that has each vertex
and then maps it to the corresponding
weight
let's create two new lists to keep track
of the neighbors and then the neighbor
weights
and so here for every single vertex
comma weight what we're going to do is
we're going to append the vertex
to self.neighbors but we're going to
append
the weight to self.neighbor weights and
so then we can easily pass these into
random.choices
so here we can do random.choices
self.neighbors
self.neighbor weights
alrighty we actually see that
random.choices
returns a list so we'll have to index
and get
you know there's it's a list of size one
but we still have to get
the first item in the list so we have to
index at zero
now we can get our next word but where
are we generating these probability maps
under graph we can create a function
called generate probability mappings
that'll get all the probability mappings
of every single vertex
here we're going to say for every vertex
in self.vertices.values
well what we're going to do is we're
going to call that vertex
and we're going to say hey get the
probability map and so then as soon as
we call that function
every single vertex will be initialized
with the probability map
and that is our graph representation so
now let's move over
to compose that pi let's think about
what we actually need to do here
well we need to get the words from the
text right
and we need to create a graph where the
values of the vertices in that graph
are those words and then for x number of
words that's defined by the user
we need to get the next word and then
we'll just show those results to the
user
so let's put all of these inside a main
function let's start with step one
getting the words from the text we can
create a function
called get word from text very original
and pass in the path to whatever text
that we're trying to get the words from
we can use this command with open text
path comma
r r stands for read as f
well we can read everything in that text
if we call f.read
and assign that to a variable text so
this is going to be a string
and now what we want to do is we kind of
want to split across all the white space
and then join it with one single white
space so what this is going to do is
like
if there's like multiple lines like you
know
indents whatever it just creates like
it gets rid of all those and replaces it
with a single space
so text.split is going to split all of
that
you know white space whatever it is tabs
spaces
um enters and replace it with
a space so for example text that
looks like this would become text
that looks like this with only spaces
all right and then what we're going to
do is we're going to lowercase
everything because it's easier to
compare everything
when it's lowercase and then now let's
not try to deal with punctuation because
stuff can get a little bit complex right
there are cases where you might want to
add a period but it's not actually the
end of the sentence
it might be an abbreviation like for
example
bright side but mister is not actually
the end of the sentence so what we're
going to do here is we're just going to
remove
all the punctuation and we can do that
by calling string dot make trans
that's make translation string we can
import string that's the python package
string.punctuation is just going to be
you know any of the punctuation
that you can see in a string and what
we're going to do is replace that
with empty strings so here's something
like hello
it's me might become hello it's me
and then of course we want to split all
the words
and we're gonna do that by just
splitting on spaces again
so we can call text.split then we're
just going to return
the list of words so return words
so under step one we can say words
equals
get words from text and then pass in the
path
to for example let's use harry potter so
text slash
hp sorcerer's stone that's the name of
the text file dot txt
that's our step one right there now the
next thing we want to do is make a graph
using those words so let's define a
function make graph and pass in the
words
here we have to import the graph in the
vertex from this graph.pi file
so up here from graph import graph comma
vertex
and then g let's assign this to a new
graph
and for each word in words we're going
to check
that the word is in the graph and
if it's not then we add it and so when
we're going through this words list
if we come across a new word then we
want to check the previous word
if it exists which it should unless
you're at like the very first word
in the whole paragraph so if there was a
previous word then we add an edge
if it didn't already exist in the graph
otherwise we increment the weight of the
existing edge
by one and then we set our word to the
previous word
and we iterate
and so now remember that like in order
to get the next word we have to set the
probability mappings
and so this is a great place to do it
right before we return the graph object
in our make graph function so let's
start on this implementation
for word in words we're going to check
that the word is in the graph
and if not then we're going to add it
so let's drag graph.pi over here so we
can look at both simultaneously
okay so you'll see that in get vertex we
actually
add the vertex already so all we need to
do is we can say
word vertex equals graph dot get vertex
and then that word if there was a
previous word then we add an edge if it
doesn't exist in the graph
otherwise we increment the weight by one
so here let's actually create a previous
word variable
and assign it to none because at the
very beginning there is a previous word
here we're going to check
if previous word then previous word dot
increment
edge word vertex right because what this
is going to do it's going to increment
that edge between the previous word
and the word vertex by one
and here the increment edge already does
that for you
because we've implemented that in our
vertex already
now here all we have to do is set
previous word equal to
whatever this word is so that in our
next iteration we have access to the
previous word
and we keep doing that for all words and
at the very end we can say
g dot generate probability mappings
generate all the probability mappings
and then return that graph
all right so step two g equals make
graph and then we pass in the words that
we got
from get words from text
now step three we want to get the next
word for x number of words as defined by
the user
let's create a function compose given
a graph and given the words and some
length
let's just say 50 for now we're going to
create a composition and this is at
first
going to be an empty list every single
time that
we generate a new word we're just going
to put it into this list
composition and what we can say is that
well look we have the words list
let's just get some random word from
this words list
and you know grab that vertex from g and
this is where we're starting so for
however many iterations in the length
that the user has defined
we're just going to iterate and we're
going to keep getting the next word
right
here we can say composition.append
and then this word which is the word
vertex
we're going to append the value of that
vertex because remember we can't
actually append the vertex and have that
legible
we have to append what word that vertex
corresponds to
and then now our next word is going to
be g dot
get next word given the current word
so here we can say word equals g dot get
next word
and this current word and what we're
going to do is replace this word
variable and keep getting the next one
at the very end we're just going to
return our composition
all right now down here in our main
function again we can say our
composition
equals compose we can pass in g we can
pass in words
and then we can pass in some parameter
length override that we can say 100 for
the heck of it
we don't want to just return a list
let's actually return a string
so we can join this list of words by a
space
and so this is going to return a string
where all the words and composition
are just separated by a space
so now let's run this function and
generate
okay and because we're returning this
composition we're not printing it
let's print whatever main returns
and that's how we're going to see our
composition
alrighty so first we can try running and
look at that
random is not defined i forgot to define
that
so i go back up here and i'm going to
import
random save that and run it again
all right so now none type has no
attribute value so this means that
this word dot value
word is somehow none
so how in the world do we fix that so
let's go back into our graph code
and take a look at what's going on it
could be g dot
vertex or g dot get next word one of
those is probably returning none
so let's open graph.pi
and if we look at get next word okay
here we're calling next word but oh look
we're never actually returning a value
and so that's our bug let's add a return
statement there
and let's try writing this again
and there we go it worked let's read
this this is built off of our harry
potter
text do you
are some interesting so unfair that
strangers
they were going to let her to squeeze
him
i want to look at it had one who
has always marooned tailcoat's orange
eyes
away just hope of his last look back
tur anyone else is very well no answer
professor carroll had
been a bundle of white a clear field
harry ron
all right so this is kind of cool
but clearly this you know it's some
gibberish
and the reason for that is just because
our implementation of
simply a markov chain is not very
intelligent right we're kind of just
randomly choosing given this word
pick a next word one way that we could
make it better
and more slightly like english is
instead of saying like
hey this word maybe choose like the
previous like three words
right and then pick the next word based
off of the previous three words
and so on just so that it has some sort
of memory so it doesn't jump around
as much but now maybe you're interested
in can we do this with the songs that i
have in here
and i'm going to show you exactly how to
implement that
we can edit a couple of things but keep
most of the logic the same
if we go into like one of billy eilish's
song for example you'll see that we have
this like chorus
verse thing in brackets and that's
obviously not like part of the song so
we're gonna remove like the bracket and
the text
inside of it we can do that with
a regex again so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna say hey substitute
and then this funky expression which i'm
gonna explain
just a bit but substitute that with the
space
anywhere in the text it's saying this is
the left bracket this is right bracket
and here this dot plus so the dot means
any character and plus means one or more
so this means if there's one or more
characters inside the brackets
then replace any version of that with a
space
in the text and so here in order to use
this we have to import
re and let's reformat some of
this stuff okay and so the rest of this
should be the same because we still want
to get rid of white space we still want
to get rid of punctuation
but instead of just you know one
file name we actually have multiple
right in this folder
and one way that we can like just have
python read that folder rather than
having to type out every single file
name is if we import os
and we go down here we can actually
walk through this folder and find all of
the file names
within that folder so let's do that
right here
okay so for song file
in here we're going to use os dot
list dir so that's list directory
songs and then we're gonna pass in an
artist name
okay so here we're gonna use the
f-string
pass in the artist and then in main
we're gonna pass in the artist
so what this is gonna do is if you pass
in this artist's name to align with that
file name for example billy underscore
irish
then we're going to list every single
file that's under that folder
and here you know for green day
you have all these for lincoln park you
have all these
and so on all right so after i get all
these song files i can
now call get words from text and pass
in this path songs
artist dash and then whatever the song
file is
so here i'm gonna put that in here song
file
and so this is just gonna get every
single song file and like
go through and get the words from that
and up here i'm going to define words
equals an empty list
and then every single time we get a
song's words we're just going to add
that to the words
list so we can extend by whatever song
words is and so now down here
we want to input the artist so let's
input taylor swift
let's try running this
okay so we're getting an error and
usually i would just google this error
honestly this isn't one that i'm super
familiar with
let's actually print what the song files
are so we can figure out
which one it failed at and so here if we
run this we actually see that it failed
at this file called
ds store and so this is just some cache
that's stored under this directory it's
not actually a song file itself
and so we can just say like if this
equals
dot ds door then continue because we're
just going to keep going the loop
and so if we run compose.pi again
look there's our taylor swift
masterpiece i remember thinking
are we in red because there you
breathless
hmm or it's time you need to calm down
you're sorry for it used to hit you
again even if it's such a chance to
paper airplanes flying
flying and i'd never looked back
together
etc again this is kind of gibberish
we could make it more intelligent but
for now as a beginner project
this is pretty cool you're generating
paragraphs
based off of some vocabulary that you're
inputting through
songs or harry potter etcetera
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
subscribe to my channel
follow me on instagram and twitter at
kylie y
ying if you guys are interested in live
coding sessions
where you know they're not pre-planned
like these tutorials
you should definitely follow me on
twitch kylie ying
alright hope to see you guys around i
hope you guys enjoyed my videos
and yeah see you later